une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités datite chute d'une plante
j'anime le podcast avec pH Quentin et
cette semaine on reçoit au podcast
Christian page qui journaliste
chroniqueur et qui est au Québec pas mal
la référence en termes de paranormal
tout ce qui a très finalement au
paranormal soit les fantômes soit les
ovnis soit les théories du complot
vraiment bizarre
Christian page c'est un mordu de
paranormal il connaît tout ce qu'il y a
à savoir sur le sujet il peut vous
expliquer toutes les théories du complot
d'où ça vient c'est vraiment fascinant
de de l'entendre nous raconter toutes
ces histoires là Christian page en fait
il y a un point de vue de sceptique de
journalistes par rapport à ça aussi
intéressant ça veut dire qu'il croit
nécessairement à toutes ces histoires là
il nous a raconté un petit peu son
histoire en fait on est parti de sa
jeunesse il y a vécu une expérience
paranormale
finalement puis après après cette
expérience là il était convaincu croyait
en toutes ces toutes ces choses-là et
puis avec le temps à force de se
renseigner à force de faire des
recherches mais son regard est devenu
plus sceptique plus critique par rapport
à tout ça alors c'est super intéressant
il a posé des questions sur absolument
tout
sur les phénomènes de portugaise sur le
Mons du Loch Ness sur les ovnis à Area
51 pour nommer que cela c'était vraiment
super fascinant je pense qu'on aurait pu
parler encore des heures Christian pages
et inarrêtable c'est fou le savoir que
ces gars-là détient alors c'était
vraiment super plaisant un grand bonheur
d'avoir reçu et j'espère que vous allez
aimer la conversation alors bonne écoute
et bon podcast
le podcast aujourd'hui est une
présentation de rebelle fashion une
compagnie québécoise de bas sont tous
des amis à Montréal et comme vous pouvez
voir j'emporte présentement pour ceux
qui nous regardent en vidéo j'ai mes
pieds sur la table avec ses merveilleux
citrons j'ai aussi choisi les plumes de
Pan et les plus classiques noirs avec
des petits motifs il y en a vraiment
pour tous les goûts c'est sûr que vous
allez trouver le bas idéal ou les bas
idéal pour vous et là le temps des fêtes
approche et des beaux bas c'est vraiment
un excellent cadeau à faire à votre chum
à votre frère à votre beau-père
n'importe qui dans le fond qui porte des
bas 60% ou presque de la population
ça a quand même Justin Trudeau apporter
il porte les bords à belfasten et son
son préféré serait le modèle habillé
mauve alors on a un code promo pour vous
c'est sans filtre en un mot ça vous
offre 20% de rabais sur votre première
commande alors n'hésitez pas courir
allez vous acheter des bas rebelles
fashion sont beaux sont de qualité sont
doux les couleurs sont éclatantes vous
serez pas déçu et c'est sûr que vous
allez trouver un bas sur lequel vous
tripez et en plus encourager une
compagnie québécoise alors let's go
rebelle fashion.ca le podcast est
présenté par nos amis chez manscape
manscape on en parle tellement souvent
on en parle littéralement à chaque
podcast parce que parce que on adore les
produits parce que de tout évidente vous
aussi vous adorez les produits parce que
on a un excellent retour demain contents
de collaboration on fait qu'on continue
comme ça même Skype c'est des produits
pour l'entretien de ta peau de ta
pilosité de tes cheveux de de ton poil
en fait de tout c'est un vraiment 3,60
puis là aussi de prédilection c'est le
landmore le landmore
c'est un Clipper qui a et warpool
premièrement ce qui est l'aspect
principal qui est qui a une technologie
qui t'empêche de [ __ ] les bases c'est
vraiment un Clipper ultime pour tout que
ce soit en dessous de la ceinture ta
face d'homme chez toi tout un grand
concentrateur de mannequin l'utilisateur
il y a plein de produits moi j'aime
beaucoup aussi le petit rasoir
que je trouve qu'il va vraiment vraiment
bien puis les produits
comme le parfum shampoing body wash le
parfum je le dis souvent je reçois des
commentaires quand je le mets je le mets
juste quand je sors quand je vois dans
une petite soirée là quand vient le
temps de donner deux becs à des amis que
tu vois actuellement tu chantes bon mais
c'est magnifique
puis on a un code promo pour vous ils
ont une multitude de paquets de toutes
sortes avec toutes leurs produits vous
pouvez aller voir tout ça sur leur site
web mais assurez-vous utiliser le code
promo sans filtre parce que vous allez
avoir 20% rabais vous allez avoir le
shopping gratuit Puiseux ils vont savoir
que c'est nous qui vous envoie ça ça
nous a ça nous aide beaucoup ça
encourage beaucoup le podcast fake
continuez comme ça continuez à
encourager m'inscrire contenant de nous
encourager et puis offrez-vous le cadeau
des bases propres dans le fond
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être là ce matin ça me
fait plaisir merci d'avoir invité ça
fait plaisir on tourne aujourd'hui mais
tu réalises ce matin qu'on tournait ce
podcast là le jour de lawrin
effectivement pour parler de
probablement parler de paranormal puis
de tout ça si vous m'avez invités
mondiale du paranormal en ligne bah en
fait c'est surtout dans les milieux dans
les pays anglo-saxons que c'est fort on
le retrouve aussi dans des pays où ça
débordé comme la France par exemple
c'est moins populaire en France mais
c'est vrai que dans les pays
anglo-saxons la fête de l'Halloween est
une fête excessivement populaire
en Amérique vous pouvez le dire
excusez-moi de vous expliquer
la fête la plus commerciale après Noël
c'est en train de rivaliser avec Noël
sur le plan commercial c'est très
populaire donc comme tu me disais avant
qu'on tourne c'est une grosse journée
pour toi aussi
niveau télévision on veut tout savoir
une petite histoire de fantôme à se
mettre sous la dent
on s'imagine on va appeler Christian
page c'est sûr qu'il va avoir quelque
chose à nous raconter il va avoir une
histoire de fantôme histoire de fantômes
on a parlé aussi à avant qu'on tourne
puis l'histoire qui t'a amené au
paranormal tu le raconter maintenant une
fois peut-être qu'on l'a rencontré pas
en détail mais juste pour les gens qui
sachent d'où tu viens et ça écoute ton
parcours si tu es arrivé une histoire là
donc il faut toujours se rappeler je
mets là je mets toujours la mise en
garde faut toujours se rappeler qu'on ne
raconte jamais un événement raconte
toujours le souvenir que l'on a de
l'événement donc en gros on note deux
aspects il y a deux niveaux à la à la
vérité en fait il a une vérité
psychologique ce que moi je crois que
c'est passé la vérité factuelle si
j'avais placé une caméra sur le bord de
la route ce qui est de remontrer donc ça
peut être une fois deux choses très
différentes pour moi le paranormal a
débuté le 13 juillet 19 1976 à ce moment
là j'étais un adolescent j'avais 13 ans
je m'intéressais pas au phénomène
paranormaux on est dans les années 70
comme n'importe quel jeune de cette
époque là on avait vu à la télé des
séries des envahisseurs et compagnies
donc le paranormal existait mais il
existait pour moi de manière éloignée
c'était Hollywood là le paranormal et
puis comme tous les jeunes de 13-14 ans
mon intérêt au milieu des années 70
c'était testostérone oblige j'étais les
filles c'était le rock n' roll c'était
sa grande période là donc c'était une
époque où tout le monde il est fait tout
le monde il est gentil parce que je
raconte ça aujourd'hui que les gens mon
Dieu 13 ans il faisait de l'auto-stop
c'était tout le monde il est fait tout
le monde il est gentil donc on se
rappeler
et donc ce jour-là je quittais des amis
j'avais passé la journée à Saint-Paul de
l'île aux Noix pour les gens qui nous
écoutent c'est un petit village tout
près de la frontière américaine sur la
route 223 et donc je marchais en
direction de Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu où
j'habitais à l'époque on a une distance
après une quinzaine vingtaine de et donc
je suis sorti le faut dire saint Paul
Delémont c'est un tout petit village un
agglomération de quelques maisons dans
ce qui forme le centre-ville et quelques
habitations autour mais c'est tout donc
je n'ai de quitter la partie éclairée du
centre-ville qui se limitait une
station-service et indépendante et là on
a on a effectivement des lampadaires
tous les 30 ou 40 mètres à peu près mais
pour se situer dans le contexte de
l'environnement ce sont des terres
agricoles on a donc une rue
et c'est donc c'est un chemin rural de
chaque côté on a d'importants faussés
puis ensuite on a des terres agricoles
et dans le dans les incidents qui va qui
va survenir je me je marche donc le long
de cette route il y a des fossés de
chaque côté de moi et derrière moi il y
a un grand champ qui est souvent un
champ de maïsme en réalité c'est un
champ qui avait été laissé la chair donc
qui était foin sauvage et comme je me
trouve dans une zone qui est assez
sombre à l'extérieur du village
joint de voiture qui s'en vient et on
réinvente pas la roue je l'ai mentionné
on est le 13 juillet 1976 le soleil est
couché je sais pas l'heure mais comme le
soleil se couche tardivement 28h30
quelque chose comme ça doit être à peu
près 10 heures à ce moment-là 22h donc
la voiture ça sort du village elle vient
du village elle se dirige vers moi et à
ce moment-là comme la voiture arrive à
peu près à ma hauteur je tends le pouce
est-ce que le chauffeur me joue au
dernier moment difficile à dire mais
comme il arrive à ma hauteur il a donné
un coup de volant et test pour me faire
peur ou a été surpris de ma présence et
à cette époque dans les années 70
c'était ce qu'on appelait des voitures à
propulsion ou attraction arrière donc en
donnant ce coup de roue le véhicule
s'est mis un peu au travail de travers
les roues arrière le train arrière est
tombé dans le gravier puis elle s'est
mettre dérapé à ce moment-là je suis
persuadé que je vais être frappé par la
voiture et comme la voiture arrive à mon
contact j'ai l'impression j'ai pu sauter
non on s'entend bien là je raconte
l'histoire tel que je j'ai eu
l'impression d'être soulevé du sol donc
je me suis pas élancé j'étais soulevé du
sol la voiture est passée sous mes pieds
en fait à la hauteur de la malle arrière
et au moment où la voiture passait je me
rappelle que je pouvais bouger mes pieds
j'étais suspendu à peu près à 2,50 m
dans les heures et j'ai pu boucher mes
pieds je me disais mais c'était
incroyable j'avais l'impression de
flotter dans l'air
une fois la voiture passée j'ai retombé
dans le fossé qui bordait la route mais
tombé entendons-nous j'ai tombé mais
légèrement doucement un peu comme un
trapéziste qui aurait un Arnaud autour
de la taille puis on a déposé dans le
français le temps de me relever je vois
que la voiture a commencé à s'éloigner
leur elle a retrouvé son appel sur la
chaussée je vois les phares arrière qui
s'éloignent le chauffeur ne s'est jamais
arrêté peut-être que même pas eu mais
peut-être rien vu de ce qu'il venait de
se passer et au moment où je me relève
dans le fossé je suis pas blessé rien
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des gens
autour de moi et à ce moment-là je sens
des mains qui m'agrippent on me couche
sur le ventre et on m'amène dans ce
fameux champ là en friche et quand je
dis on m'amène on m'a soulevé du sol
donc je me trouve peut-être à 45 cm au
dessus du sol je flotte dans l'air je
l’impression de flotter tu vois pas
c'est ça je les sens une
rappelons-le comme ça l'agresseur un
agresseur me tient par les bras à la
hauteur réponds un peu plus bas que les
épaules et un autre me tient par les
chevilles donc on me lève du sol et on
va mettre dans le champ c'est pas un
mouvement je flotte pas comme si j'étais
sur un tapis volant mais il y a un
mouvement un oscillation de haut en bas
comme des gens qui marchent et là
j'entends des voix une première voix
vient à la hauteur de mes chevilles et
elle dit on voit le tuer on va le tuer
et l'autre il y a une autre voix qui
n'est pas celui qui me tient par les
épaules mais qui semble marcher en avant
comme s'il y avait un éclaireur à la
troupe qui lui répond non on va
seulement lui faire peur seulement lui
faire peur et ce mouvement-là continue
j'ai beau me tourner la tête de gauche à
droite je suis comme paralysé et je ne
vois personne et puis après avoir
franchi peut-être une distance de 50
mètres on me repose sur le sol je sens
de pression entre mes omoplates je
m'attends à recevoir un coup sur la tête
quelque chose comme ça et rien ne se
produit tout s'arrête
à la pression se relâche mieux plus rien
j'entends à nouveau sa c'est curieux
est-ce que je le réalise à ce moment-là
mais j'ai comme l'impression que
j'entends à nouveau le vent qui souffle
dans les arbres j'entends le bruit des
feuilles je me retourne je suis assis
dans mon champ à 50 mètres de la route
il n'y a plus rien donc cette expérience
là qui est unique j'en aurais pas
d'autres là je ne promène je n'ai pas de
médaille puis je vais t'enlever par les
extraterrestres mais cette expérience là
elle est très marquante il m'a fallu
plus de temps vous la raconter ce matin
qu'elle ne durée en réalité
lorsque je suis arrivé chez moi le
lendemain je suis allé à la bibliothèque
municipale de mon quartier et pour voir
des livres sur le surnaturel est-ce que
nous vous rejoins revécu des histoires
semblables je savais bien que les gens
avaient des ouvrages sur les fantômes
les soucoupes volantes on en avait à
l'école mais j'étais surpris de voir à
la bibliothèque municipale les rayons
complets de livres sur les phénomènes
paranormaux et là je réalise en fait que
ce sont des phénomènes beaucoup plus
courants que les médias de l'époque en
parlait parce qu'il faut se rappeler le
dans les années 70 ici au Québec on
avait trois chaînes francophones on
avait télémétropole qui est devenu TVA
on avait Radio-Canada en français et on
avait radio Québec qui est devenu
Télé-Québec c'est un état qu'on avait et
ces médias jamais de phénomènes
paranormaux de temps en temps des
émissions claire la marche par exemple à
droite parole qui était radio Québec
vous pouvez faire une émission spéciale
croyez vos fantômes croyez vos
extraterrestres mais c'était des
émissions marginales par rapport à
l'information qui circulait alors là je
découvre tout un univers et depuis à
l'époque pour le dire j'ai été
adolescent j'étais un peu comme une
éponge j'absorbais toutes les
informations et probablement par un
aspect culturel on nous enseignait à
l'école si c'est dans le livre c'est que
c'est vrai donc si je lisais des
ouvrages on me disait que les soucoupes
volantes étaient vraies les
extraterrestres les fantômes et tout le
reste évidemment j'accepte ça comme
étant une réalité
aujourd'hui évidemment j'ai pris
beaucoup de recul par rapport à ça mais
à partir de là l'univers du paranormal
s'est ouvert à moi et
je veux simplement finir avec ça et
éventuellement c'est ce n'est pas le
journaliste qui m'a amené au paranormal
mais le paranormal qui m'a amené au
journaliste donc d'une certaine façon ça
a été l'événement le plus marquant de ma
vie
lorsque je suis allé en journaliste je
trouvais que les phénomènes paranormaux
étaient si extraordinaire je me disais
il faut en parler davantage puis il faut
en parler de manière rigoureuse et
sérieuse je vais éviter de dire on en a
parlé avant d'entrer en ondes mais c'est
j'ai évoqué avant qu'on entre en onde
que c'était le deuxième phénomène social
et culturel de plus important qui fait
appel aux croyances après les grandes
religions donc on a à peu près de son
regard au Canada d'une façon moyenne on
a 63% des gens qui se définissent comme
croyant que ce soit catholique que ce
soit musulman peu importe mais 63% de
croyants et on a 51% de qui disent
croire aux paranormal quel que soit le
phénomène fantôme extraterrestre c'est
le deuxième phénomène le plus important
en termes de croyance ça mérite bien
qu'on en discute qu'on en discute
sérieusement et aujourd'hui 46 ans après
ces événements dans mon champ de mon
champ de maïsme je suis encore ici à
vous en parler parce que c'est une
passion qui ne marche jamais quitté j'ai
pris du recul par rapport au paranormal
mais croyances sont peaufinés améliorés
mon sens critique s'est développé à
cause de cette formation de journaliste
mais le paranormal est quelque chose qui
est intégré dans ma vie c'est ma façon
d'être on peut on pourra jamais sortir
le paranormal de Christian père
ma question est assez de base quand on
entend
paranormal à quoi est-ce qu'on fait
référence parce que tu sais tout le
monde tout le monde
beaucoup de personnes que je connais ils
ont eu des épisodes de leur vie des
véhicules des moments où est-ce que tu
dis ça peut pas être un hasard c'est ce
genre de truc là après ça certains ont
vu des livres bouger dans leur
bibliothèque mais tout le monde a vécu
des certaines affaires qui sortent de du
normal est-ce que pour être considéré
comme paranormal faut simplement que ça
sorte de ce qu'on entend comme la
normalité tu as raison le mot paranormal
est un mot très généraliste qui est
devenu un peu un fourre-tout de
n'importe quoi je dirais que deux
niveaux le paranormal c'est juste ce qui
sort de la normalité mais sans faire
appel nécessairement à de l'exotisme
quand on tombe dans l'exotisme on ne
parle plus de paranormal mais de
surnaturel
dans le terme du paranormal lui-même on
aurait tendance à inclure les
extraterrestres quoi que les
extraterrestres c'est pas vraiment
paranormal les phénomènes paranormaux
défini davantage des phénomènes qui se
produisent en dehors du cadre de la
normalité d'eau par anormale et c'est
amusant parce que quand j'ai mentionné
que 51% des gens dans les grands pays
industrialisés les grands pays
occidentaux disent croire un phénomène
paranormal tu l'as bien mentionné
l'éventail donc ça peut être des gens
qui croient avoir vu des fantômes mais
ça peut être aussi des gens qui ont
simplement croire par exemple au hasard
ne crois pas au hasard c'est à dire
croix ou tarot la destinée donc c'est
très très varié et ce qui est amusant
quand on regarde les gens qui défiquent
qui disent croire un phénomène
paranormal 30% d'entre eux c'est quand
même énorme le 30% d'entre eux disent
avoir vécu une expérience personnelle
liée par anormale là encore l'éventail
est très très large surtout dans le
discours populaire on peut parler de
quelqu'un qui dit moi il y a des
fantômes chez moi mais ça peut être
aussi quelqu'un qui a un matin c'est
élevé
en pensant son cousin Henri est allé au
dépanneur chez Henri sur le boulevard
Henri dans Saint-Henri et au moment où
il y a jette sa tablette de chocolat au
Henni tombe sur son cousin Henri qui
n'avait pas vu depuis des années toutes
ces coïncidences qui vont se qui vont
pas qui vont tomber comme des dominos
mais les gens diront ben c'est
incroyable ça doit être paranormal c'est
de la synchronicité donc on voit qu'on
l'éventail est large en quelqu'un qui
dit que j'ai été enlevé par des
extraterrestres et quelqu'un qui
rencontre son cousin Henri au dépanneur
chez Henri c'est vaste mais ce sont des
phénomènes qui sont un peu en marge de
la normalité maintenant on peut
évidemment dans le discours populaire on
va plus large on va inclure des
phénomènes plus extraordinaires
l'intervention des anges l'intervention
des extraterrestres mais tout ça
regroupe effectivement le domaine du
paranormal quoique parfois paranormal et
surnaturel il y a une frontière entre
les deux qui se chevauchent assez
aisément donc à cette époque-là après
cette incidence là
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup plus le
regard sceptique sur du journaliste sur
toutes ces choses là mais à l'époque
vous êtes plutôt croyant si on va
absolument si c'est quoi en fait les
domaines outils les les
théories du complot ou tu sais c'est
plus les ovnis qui vous intéressez aussi
plus les fantômes c'était quoi votre
champ d'intérêt puis à quoi vous croyez
le plus à cette époque là maintenant à
cette époque là il y avait un incident
qui est arrivé un peu en parallèle à
cette expérience là de l'agression entre
dans le champ de maïs immédiatement
après ces événements là j'ai cherché à
avoir des réponses j'étais allais à la
bibliothèque tout ça et quelques jours
après cet événement là le journal local
le Hebdo a un de
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu le Canada
français publie en première page des
gens témoins de phénomènes lumineux à la
pas à la plage brûlée il faut savoir que
la plage Brunet est à peu près à la même
haut que saint Paul de l'île aux Noix
j'ai vu que mon expérience mais de
l'autre côté de la rivière Richelieu
donc on est presque face à face et là
donc je prends connaissance de cet
article dans la dernière semaine du mois
de juillet mon expérience se produite le
3 le 13 juillet et l'on raconte que dans
la dernière semaine du mois de juillet
donc quelques jours après des gens à la
plage Brunet il faut savoir que c'est un
aménagement un peu de vacances avec des
chalets donc des gens qui
occupaient des chalets aurait été témoin
pendant 5 soirées consécutives de
phénomènes lumineux dans le ciel qu'ils
ont attribué à des extraterrestres des
soucoupes volantes comme on disait à
l'époque et il y avait un groupe très
sérieux à cette époque qui s'appelait
UFO Québec qui était composé évidemment
d'amateur mais il y avait à la tête de
UF au Québec quelques individus qui
avaient des formations académiques et je
pense que l'approche était assez
rigoureuse
donc ces gens se sont rendus à la plage
Brunet ont rencontré des témoins et puis
ils ont donné des entrevues au
journalistes donc l'article racontait
ses événements immédiatement j'ai fait
leur approchement moi je vis une
expérience étrange le 13 juillet
Saint-Paul de l'île Noire et quelques
jours plus tard des gens de l'autre côté
de la rivière voient des phénomènes
mystérieux et là il y avait un encadré
on nous disait
UF au Québec cette association disait si
vous avez été témoin d'un phénomène
étrange durant cette même période
peut-être pas forcément ces mêmes dates
là mais dans la même période pour
forcément la plage Brunet mais dans les
environs veuillez qu'on nous contacter
alors moi je me suis dit il y avait
peut-être un lien entre ces ovnis
observer mon expérience j'ai pris
contact avec eux j'ai rencontré un titre
qui s'appelait Claude macdov qui est
décédé depuis quelques années maintenant
mais qui a été un peu mon menteur au
sein de cette de cet univers du
paranormal donc je lui raconte mon
histoire il ne voit pas de lien entre ça
et les ovnis mais comme je m'étais mis
un peu le pied dans la porte de UFO
Québec je me j'ai commencé à me
documenter sur leur publication il
faisait un petit fanzine sur les ovnis
donc j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à ça
et très rapidement je me suis retrouvé
davantage impliqué dans le phénomène des
ovnis
et il y a un aspect social aussi à ça
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
associations il faut logiques versus les
associations de fantômes par la
psychologie on voit que majoritairement
le phénomène des ovnis attirent les gens
de sexe masculin et les femmes sont
plutôt portées sur des phénomènes de
fantômes des phénomènes de clairvoyance
parce que ça fait davantage appel
peut-être vos émotions alors que le
phénomène des ovnis beaucoup plus
mécaniques plus
c'est plus tôt les boulons si un moteur
là-dedans comment ça fonctionne donc on
est un peu plus dans ce genre là alors
que les femmes sont portées vers des
trucs connectés avec l'autre là donc des
phénomènes qui font appel davantage aux
émotions quant à la parapsychologie là
on est vraiment dans un univers où on
s'adresse à une forme d'élite
intellectuelle parce que le discours des
parapsychologues il est très très loin
on a tendance des chasseurs de fantômes
même bien se endosser le manteau des
parapsychologues mais il faut avoir
côtoyé le milieu de la parapsychologie
pour savoir que les parapsychologues les
chasseurs de fantômes n'ont rien de ça
donc c'est vraiment un univers
multi pôle et c'est vrai que les ovnis
étaient restés davantage et c'est encore
c'était vrai à l'époque c'est encore
vrai aujourd'hui intéresse davantage les
garçons les hommes que les phénomènes de
la clairvoyance qui intéresse davantage
les femmes
moi je l'écoutais sur le Podcast de
Gérald puis moi ce qui m'intéresse le
plus quand on parle du paranormal c'est
d'essayer de comprendre
comment est-ce qu'on peut en arriver à
avoir
à vivre une expérience paranormale
quelles sont les explications possibles
même si certaines événements demeurent
sans explication d'essayer de le
comprendre puis dans l'exemple de de
l'agression appelons là comme ça
tu disais que des années plus tard tu
avais réentendu tu avais entendu un film
traduction française à la télévision tu
as entendu ces voix-là les mêmes voies
que tu avais entendu des années plus
tard 7 ans plus tard je crois pour
remplacer vos auditeurs et c'est donc à
partir de là je deviens un obsédé du
paranormal je lis tous les ouvrages tout
qui publications qui restent quand même
assez marginale on avait des magazines
en librairie mais ça reste difficile
d'accès il y avait à peu près aucune
publication francophone qui arrivait ici
il y avait quelques magazines américains
un magazine français de temps en temps
qui était difficile à trouver en
librairie mais donc je lisais ça je
lisais tous les ouvrages je regardais à
peu près tous les films d'horreur et de
qui touchait les phénomènes sur la
naturelle peu d'émissions documentaires
il y en avait quelques-unes aux
États-Unis mais encore là ça restait
très marginal je pense notamment à choff
qui est animée à l'époque parler au nord
ni Moïse le fameux Monsieur Spock de
patrouille du cosmos mais ça restait
quand même très marginal et puis voilà
qu'en 1980 ou 1981 on est au tournant
des années 80 quelques années après ma
fameuse expérience dans le champ de maïs
il y a un film de fin de soirée qui est
diffusait de mémoire à télémétropole qui
était le réseau qui est le réseau TVA
maintenant c'est un cinéma de fin de
soirée et le titre du film c'était les
créatures de l'ombre film de 1973
tournée pour la télévision et en version
originale dont be ofrade of the doors je
sais que quelques années
je crois que c'est Goodyear mot del Toro
qui avait fait un remake de ce film là
qui était quand même assez éloigné de la
version originale mais ce film dont lui
offrir of the dark la version de 1973
est un film qui avait quand même marqué
l'imaginaire des amateurs de phénomènes
mystérieux étranges même si c'était un
film tourné pour la télévision et dans
ce film pour situer un peu encore une
fois les auditeurs on a un couple qui
hérite d'une maison familiale du côté
maternel et au moment où ils emménagent
dans la maison la dame découvre que la
une des pièces ou sous-sol la cheminée a
été murée donc elle pose la question
comme c'est une maison qui est dans la
famille depuis longtemps elle pose la
question à un menuisier qui il y a
quelques années avait mûri la cheminée à
la demande de sa grand-mère et l'homme
reste vague vous savez votre grand-mère
m'a demandé de mûrir la cheminée il y a
des choses qui doivent rester comme
elles sont
curiosités féminine bien sûr elle défait
la cheminée et elle va libérer des
petites créatures qui vont s'éparpiller
dans la maison et les créatures ont à
peu près la taille d'une poupée Barbie
30 cm de haut on dirait un peu comme des
mini Bigfoot ils sont toutes poilues
puis se promène un peu partout dans la
maison puis il l'appelle son cachets
derrière les rideaux dans l'obscurité de
l'appel Sally vient avec nous leur
objectif c'est de capturer cette femme
qui les a libérés pour l'amener dans
leur ancre et à un moment donné il y a
une scène où elle est sous la douche les
créatures ferment la lumière avec un
cintre parce qu'ils ne vivent que dans
l'obscurité donc ils éteignent la
lumière et là ils sont sur le plancher
de la salle de bain l'une des créatures
tient un rasoir droit ce qu'on appelle
un rasoir coupe chou et elle est avec sa
consœur et là il s'approche de la femme
qui est sous la douche et la première
créature celle qui tient le rasoir dit à
l'autre je vais la tuer je vais la tuer
et l'autre de répondre non on va
seulement lui faire peur seulement lui
faire peur et répondent ça il redonne un
peu la même la même réplique deux ou
trois fois puis ensuite la dame sort de
la douche allume la lumière et des
créatures s'enfuient lorsque j'ai vu ce
film j'ai été estomacqué c'est
exactement les mêmes voies avec la même
vibrato dans la voie un peu comme si on
parlait en se gargarisant le verbe bâtir
était exactement le même ça ne pouvait
pas être un hasard alors évidemment si
j'aurais pu j'aurais eu une
un penchant vers le surnaturel j'aurais
du probablement que le réalisateur du
film a vécu la même chose que
l'introduit dans le film mais déjà cette
époque en 1980 je commençais à
développer un sens critique je
commençais à lire des ouvrages qui
parlaient de parapsychologie c'était
également un moment où on commençait à
s'intéresser aux sciences cognitives et
on avait déjà fait quelques progrès dans
le domaine il y avait un domaine de la
parapsychologie qui avait beaucoup
marqué une période dans les années 50 ça
avait commencé un peu plus tôt quand
même au milieu des mais dans les années
50 on le fait l'éclosion d'un phénomène
qui s'appelait les vies les vies
antérieures donc ça avait commencé le
grand moment de ça c'est on est au
milieu des années 50 il y a une ménagère
du Texas qui s'appelle Verdun elle sera
éventuellement connue sous le nom de
semaine parce qu'on va publier un
ouvrage dans les années 50 fin des
années 50 qui s'appelle à la recherche
de Bridy Murphy on avait découvert
bon cette dame là avait rencontré
différentes personnes un moment donné
dans une soirée l'un d'entre eux était
un hypnotiseur il faisait des tours de
d'hypnotisme un peu comme on peut voir
aujourd'hui Messmer donc il faisait ça
dans une soirée de gala un peu il y a
découvert que cette femme retient
virginata était réceptive à l'hypnose et
dès qu'il l'a placé sous hypnose il a
commencé à lui raconter ok recule va
dans ta vie antérieure
c'était un peu du spectacle s'amuser et
là voilà que cette dame
se met à raconter qu'elle était une
Irlandaise qui vivait au 19e siècle en
Irlande début du 19e fin du 18e début du
19e raconte cette histoire cette
histoire-là va tellement intéresser
l'hypnothérapeute qu'il va avec la
collaboration de Virginia thaï et de son
époux il va faire plusieurs séances avec
elle il va les amener ils veulent
l'amener elle dans sa vie antérieure
elle va donner des détails à ce
moment-là on voit le mécanisme c'est
l'hypnose qui est utilisé pour régresser
dans la vie antérieure il fournit des
détails et éventuellement certains
détails seront confirmés d'autres seront
éliminés mais on va publier cet ouvrage
à la recherche de Brady Murphy c'est
vraiment cet ouvrage qui va marquer dans
la littérature sur le paranormal la
croyance dans les villes antérieures
comme dans les années 70 la vie après la
vie de Raymond Moody va nous réveiller
sur les expériences de mort imminente
c'est pas nouveau on en parle déjà mais
il faut il y a des moments forts et la
publication de cet ouvrage en étant mais
depuis les années 50 depuis cette
histoire-là ça évolué et maintenant les
scientifiques sont davantage là je nous
ramène à mon en 1980 au moment où je
vois ce film il y a quand même quelques
éléments qui ont été mis des pierres à
l'édifice on sait par exemple que
l'hypnose et la mémoire ça fonctionne
pas dès qu'on pose dès qu'on pense
quelqu'un en état d'hypnose dans cet
état-là il y a plus il y a plus de
filtres entre l'imaginaire et la réalité
et à partir du moment où on pose des
questions si il y a pas le souvenir la
mémoire va en inventer et au réveil ce
qui est dangereux c'est qu'au réveil le
souvenir inventé va devenir aura la même
permanence que
nous donc on va tromper la mémoire de
cette manière là on sait donc que la
mémoire et l'hypnose ça fonctionne pas
ensuite et là on avait mis à jour que en
fouillant dans la vie de Virginia thaï
dans l'ouvrage elle est décrite comme
étant rutie mais son vrai nom est
Virginia time en fouillant dans son
passé on a découvert que de temps à
autre lorsqu'elle était sous hypnose
elle pouvait lancer 3 ou 4 mots dans un
vieux dialecte irlandais langue qu'elle
n'avait jamais apprises elle pouvait
fournir des détails sur la vie en
Irlande au milieu du 19e siècle et
pourtant on n'avait pas l'impression
mais en fouillant dans la vie de
Virginia taille on a découvert que son
voisin d'en face était un Irlandais qui
s'appelait brider Murphy donc on a
commencé à comprendre ce qui s'était
probablement produit et on a mis à jour
un phénomène qu'on appelle la
cryptomniesie aujourd'hui et bien
reconnu dans le domaine de la mémoire
les spécialistes de mémoire
reconnaissent bien ça la cryptumnésie
c'est la faculté de notre mémoire
d'enregistrer de l'information mais de
la mettre de côté et lors d'un moment
particulier maman particulier ces
éléments-là vont venir se colorer à la
mémoire donc sous hypnose lorsqu'on
posait des questions monsieur brainstein
posait des questions à Virginia thaï
lorsqu'elle n'avait pas les réponses
elle allait puiser dans des informations
qu'elle avait probablement enregistrer
de manière inconsciente lorsqu'elle
avait 5 6 ou 7 ans et qu'elle vivait à
proximité de ce monsieur Murphy qui
probablement parlait de temps en temps
dans avec un patois irlandais devait
s'adresser à son épouse en utilisant des
mots irlandais et c'est ce qui
ressortait
si je transpose ça maintenant mon
expérience le film date de 1973 mon
expérience s'est produite en 1976 le
film me révèle des détails qui me
rappelle mon expérience en haut au début
des années 80 je me suis posé la
question et je me la pose encore
aujourd'hui entre 1973 et 1976 est-ce
que je n'aurais pas pu être chez des
amis ou le téléviseur aurait présenté ce
film et inconsciemment dans une autre
pièce alors que j'étais avec des amis et
puis on jouait peut-être un jeu de
société et quelque part mon cerveau a
enregistré ce dialogue et au moment de
l'expérience sur le bord de la route en
76 pour des raisons inconnues mon
cerveau a ramené le détail de ce
discours là qui est venu colorer
l'expérience ça n'explique pas tout mais
ça ne me laisse présager qu'une partie
de l'expérience a probablement été fondu
avec des éléments purement imaginaires
qui venait probablement de se mé de la
cryptomnies et tu as raison c'est
fascinant de comprendre comment notre
cerveau peut fonctionner et notre
cerveau peut nous altérer la perception
que l'on a de la réalité et nous amener
à croire au surnaturel et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut en parler davantage ce que je
trouve dommage
et encore une fois je l'ai dit avant
qu'on entre lorsque l'on parle dans les
milieux universitaires de religion qui
fait appel aux croyances on en parle
avec ouverture
sans filtre et ça va bien on parle de
l'histoire des religions pourquoi les
gens adhèrent à tel ou telle religion
les mécanismes qui sous-tend derrière
ces religions-là également les
interprétations des textes religieux
parce qu'il y a toute une symbole et que
derrière les apparitions non lorsque
Ezekiel voit un char de feu c'est pas
une soucoupe volante qui est en train de
se poser il faut décanter toute
l'information pour comprendre que un
symbolisme derrière ça symbolise et on
va pas on va pas en guerre avec des
gogos on y va avec un chariot de feu
puis le feu c'est Dieu bon on comprend
ça donc toute une symbolique derrière ça
et on en parle ouvertement sans filtre
ça va bien mais dès qu'on parle dans les
milieux académiques un petit peu moins
vrai aujourd'hui mais très longtemps dès
qu'on abordait le paranormal dans les
milieux académiques il y avait de lever
de bouclier il faut pas en parler et
pourtant ce sont des phénomènes très
importants et c'est important également
de comprendre pourquoi on croit
surnaturel et pourquoi on a tendance à
interpréter des événements qui souvent
peuvent être banals mais qui seront
perçus comme étant de nature
surnaturelle ça n'explique pas tout
quand j'ai commencé dans cet univers là
je croyais à 95% des choses en ce que je
lisais dans la littérature je me disais
95% de ça doit être vrai puis il y a
peut-être un 5% de fantaisie quand on
parlait des anges des guidons là j'étais
un peu moins convaincu donc il y avait
un 95% auquel j'adhrm aujourd'hui c'est
complètement un revers de la bascule
aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il y a à peu près un 5% de
phénomènes pour lesquels on n'a pas
d'explication ça ne nous oblige pas à
croire aux extraterrestres ou revenant
ou quoi que ce soit simplement dire on a
5 % de phénomènes pour lesquels on n'a
pas d'explication puis en soit c'est
rien d'extraordinaire dans n'importe
quel autre sphère d'activité il y a des
phénomènes qu'on n'explique pas par
exemple en physique pourquoi est-ce que
Vénus tourne dans l'autre à contre sens
des autres planètes on le sait pas
pourquoi dans le domaine médical
certains cancers vont rentrer
spontanément en rémission sans qu'il y
ait de traitement de chimiothérapie on
le sait pas ça ça coûte des cristaux
aussi voilà donc on comprend c'est il y
a des phénomènes pour lesquels on n'a
pas d'explication puis on se creuse la
tête et espérons que la science dans 10
20 ou 30 ans il va pouvoir les trouver
des expliquer donc qu'il y ait dans la
vie sociale de tous les jours des
phénomènes pour lesquels on n'a pas
d'explication que ce soit la perception
d'un défunt un phénomène lumineux dans
le ciel bah c'est tout à fait dans la
norme donc je sais aujourd'hui que 95%
de ce qu'on retrouve dans la littérature
ce que l'on retrouve dans immédiat c'est
passer moi l'expression mais c'est de la
merde c'est de la boucher on essaie de
nous vendre du rêve nous pelleter des
nuages alors qu'il y a à peu près que 5%
là-dedans qui tient la route mais c'est
5% qui fait que 46 ans plus tard je suis
toujours ici à vous en parler avec la
même passion parce que je suis fasciné
un parce qu'on peut trouver des
explications à 95% d'entre eux et la
mécanique derrière ces explications et
tout à fait extraordinaire elle nous
apprend rien sur l'au-delà nous apprend
rien sur la vie sur d'autres planètes
mais nous apprend énormément sur l'être
humain et comment on perçoit la réalité
autour de nous quant aux 5% qui ne
s'expliquent pas
la porte ouverte non seulement la
connaissance mais au souhaits
on explique pas toutes les observations
de fantômes on n'explique pas tous les
phénomènes liés ou mort imminentes
quelque part il y a peut-être notre
souhait qu'il y ait une vie après la
mort et c'est tant mieux que d'y croire
mais en même temps il faut quand même
être réaliste et regarder la recherche
qui se fait dans ces domaines-là parce
que c'est extraordinaire puis
dans ce 5% là est-ce que dans votre
carrière 46 ans plus tard il y a encore
certains événements
qui non seulement sont inexplicables ou
inexpliquées mais que vous vous dites on
parlait avant de rentrer en nombre
encore une fois de souvent l'explication
la meilleure c'est souvent la plus
simple la plus probable un joueur de
gamme est-ce que est-ce que les
événements qui encore aujourd'hui vous
dites crimes j'ai l'impression que les
explications la plus probable et par
anormale en fait il y a des phénomènes
le phénomène qui pour moi est le plus
intrigant parce qu'il a été documenté
dans des conditions rigoureuses ce sont
les phénomènes dit de poltergeist donc
si on parle des phénomènes de fantômes
on pourrait les classer en gros en deux
types de phénomènes il y a les
phénomènes de hantise ou des gens vont
dire boursiers lieux il y a des
apparitions souvent ça perdure pendant
de longues années voire des siècles
c'est l'idée du vieux château hanté de
temps en temps il y a des apparitions
que les gens vont associer à des défunts
qui auraient habité ces lieux donc ça
c'est le phénomène des hantise les
phénomènes de poltergeist qui en
français on a pour rappeler esprit
frappeur mais le nom de Marie c'est
peut-être fort c'est peut-être ce
sur-utiliser dans le cas des
poltergeistes ce sont des phénomènes qui
apparaissent de manière spontanée
peuvent apparaître un mardi matin par
exemple ils vont perdurer pendant
quelques semaines et s'arrêter aussi
subitement qu'ils sont apparus ce sont
des phénomènes qu'on dit entre
guillemets destructifs c'est-à-dire des
coups frappés dans les murs des objets
qui sont renversés des portes qui
claquent des cadres qui sont jetés sur
le plancher donc c'est violent comme
manifestation mais il n'y a généralement
quelques exceptions près mais
généralement il y a aucune apparition
associée à ces phénomènes là il se
produit c'est le chaos dans
l'environnement les phénomènes physiques
les phénomènes physiques et dans ce
chaos on sait pas pourquoi mais on a
constaté qu'il y a souvent une personne
qui a des troubles émotifs on a souvent
évoqué au début de la parade psychologie
lorsque la parade psychologie devenue
très instrumental très scientifique dans
les années 50 on parlait du syndrome de
la méchante petite fille parce qu'on
avait remarqué que dans certains cas le
poltergeist il y avait une fillette une
AD au préadolescente qui avait des
troubles émotifs et c'était comme si la
matière se mettait en résonance autour
d'elle donc au lieu lorsqu'elle est en
colère au lieu de donner un coup de
poing sur la table mais c'est une porte
qui claquait un vase qui tombait comme
si la matière réagissait à son émotion
on a constaté également qu'il y avait
aussi des petits garçons souvent
associés à ces manifestations mon en
parle de moi parce que c'était plus beau
de dire c'est la vilaine petite fille il
y a toute une aspect culturel on sait
aujourd'hui que ces éléments-là sont
même si cet agent du poltergeiste le nom
qu'on donnait à ces personnes au centre
des manifestations on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on a un éventail plus
élargi c'est pas toujours des petites
filles c'est pas toujours des petits
garçons c'est parfois ce sont des hommes
ou des femmes mais généralement il y a
une dynamique d'un problème émotif ce
sont des gens qui ne se sont pas bien
dans leur peau et c'est comme si la
matière se mettait en résonance autour
d'eux et dans certains cas ces
manifestations ont été documentées de
manière très rigoureuse donc on a on est
certain que manifestation est réelle
mais pour laquelle on n'a pas
d'explication ou quand je dis on n'a pas
d'explication comme on est sans filtre
et on a un peu de temps devant nous il y
a quand même une expérience qui a été
menée qui nous met sur une piste elle ne
nous apporte pas elle ne nous apporte
pas aucune information mécanique mais il
nous met sur une piste dans les années
1970 début des années 70 un groupe de
chercheurs en parapsychologie de Toronto
qui s'appelle la New Horizon
Foundation qui était dirigé par un
groupe très élitiste parmi eux par
exemple il y avait la directrice de
l'association médecin de l'Association
des génies qui ont plus de 140 de
quotient intellectuels donc la
directrice canadienne
Elisabeth
le nouveau revenir le jeune blanc mais
bref ce groupe là était composé de tout
un groupe de gens qui s'intéressait au
phénomène paranormaux et la question
qu'on s'est posée au moment donné c'est
est-ce que il serait possible de faire
apparaître un fantôme et
on se dit voilà on va essayer de
d'organiser une séance un peu de
spiritisme pour faire apparaître un
fantôme et cette dame Elizabeth sparo
donc on me revient qui avait une
imagination tout à fait débordante elle
dit ben voilà on va essayer de créer un
fantôme imaginaire donc tout ça c'est
sous la supervision d'un parapsychologue
reconnu spécialiste d'ailleurs des
phénomènes de poltergeistes un dénommé
George Owens qui est d'origine
britannique qui vivait à Toronto à ce
moment-là donc ces gens-là vont créer un
personnage qui n'a jamais existé bon ben
voilà il va s'appeler Philippe c'est un
aristocrate du 17e siècle on lui invente
une vie on lui invente même des traits
les gens se réunissent par chaque
semaine deux fois semaine on se réunit
dans une pièce qui a été dédiée à ça
dans la maison de George Owens et on
fait un dessin voici le portrait robot
c'est à quoi doit ressembler Philippe
doit avoir les cheveux comme les hommes
de son époque porter la barbe
on lui donne également une vie sociale
il aime telle ou tel type de musique il
est marié avec Dorothée une femme
frigide et Philippe va trouver l'amour
auprès d'une bohémienne Margaux et
éventuellement Dorothée va voir vent des
des
largeurs sur son mari dans des
infidélités de son mari et elle va
s'arranger pour faire arrêter Margaux la
bohémienne elle va la faire accuser de
sorcellerie Margot va être exécuté le
pauvre Philippe à peine 30 ans
terrassé par la douleur va se jeter du
haut des palissades de dodington Manor
en Angleterre dans tout ce qu'on devient
de raconter là il y a une seule chose de
vrai il existe bel et bien en Angleterre
un endroit qui s'appelle daddingtonmer
mais pourquoi avoir choisi un lieu réel
alors que tout le récit fictif parce que
l'on sait qu'à Eddington Manor il n'y a
jamais eu personne ressemblant de près
ou de loin à Philippe donc quel que soit
la manifestation qui se produirait
durant les séances de spiritisme si
cette personne-là disait voilà je vivais
à des dington mais on sait que quelqu'un
comme Philippe n'a jamais vécu de
dington malheur il n'y a même pas de
palissade autour de
bref ces gens-là après avoir bien
absorbé cette information vont se réunir
c'est très contraignant ils vont le
faire pendant d'abord une année complète
autour d'une table on s'imagine un peu
l'idée de la séance de spiritisme on est
long se tient les mains ça se fait dans
un environnement excessivement stère
c'est sombre mais rien ne se produit pas
de couche sous la table pas de fantôme
rien du tout alors on regarde dans la
littérature et on découvre que les
séances de spiritisme ne sont pas tout à
fait comme on l'imaginait généralement
quand on regarde le cinéma on voit des
séances de spiritisme avec une petite
lumière tamisée ou une bougie les gens
sont là c'était très Austin alors que au
milieu du 19e siècle quand le spiritisme
s'est développé il a gagné l'Europe très
populaire aussi en Amérique les séances
de spiritisme se faisaient de manière
beaucoup plus conviviale certes la
lumière était parfois tamisée mais les
gens se racontaient des blagues on
parlait autour de la table c'était
beaucoup plus détendu comme atmosphère
donc Giorgio qui est supervise
l'expérience de Philippe Le Fantôme
décide d'adopter ces nouvelles règles on
va changer la dynamique donc les gens se
réunissent encore une fois tous les
toutes les semaines on se met autour de
la table mais on le fait avec la lumière
il y a des caméras placées sous bois
sous la table des suit la table pour
s'assurer que il peut pas y avoir de
manipulations puis ce serait étonnant
qu'il y a une manipulation par une
manipulation parce que tous ces gens-là
il y a pas de médium dans ce groupe là
il y a rien à attendre on est un groupe
de chercheurs c'est le groupe D8 c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle les gens qui
sont autour de la table il y a des
superviseurs mais c'est une expérience à
caractère scientifique et après quelques
mois la table se met à réagir d'abord
des petits coups en dessous de la table
et ensuite les mouvements à partir du
moment où il y a des petits coups il va
y avoir une accélération des des
manifestations donc la table va se
soulever littéralement à parfois elle va
se basculer sur une pâte va tourner au
milieu de la pièce
des gens eux ont la main sur le plateau
et pour s'assurer qu'il ne puisse pas
pousser la table d'un côté de l'autre
ils ont souvent du papier ciré sous les
doigts donc c'est la main qui glisserait
sur le dessus de la table et pourtant ça
n'empêche jamais la table de bouger et
la table répond aux questions des
participants toujours en accord avec la
biographie de Philippe donc bien sûr la
il y a pas de fantôme malheureusement il
y a des groupes à produire le fantôme
mais la table réagit et l'esprit de la
table appelé on le comme ça c'est bel et
bien Philippe il dit je suis Philippe et
quand on lui pose des questions on
établit un nombre un code oui deux coups
pour oui un coup pour non et les
réponses de Philips sont toujours en
accord avec sa biographie quand on pose
des questions à Philippe qui ne sont pas
dans sa biographie la table reste
silencieuse mais si on réadapte à
nouveau la biographie de Philippe en y
ajoutant de nouveaux éléments la table
va réagir en fonction de ces nouveaux
éléments
c'est très spectaculaire la fraude est
complètement éclipsée on peut éliminer
la fraude est-ce que ce que l'expérience
de Philippe montre c'est que la volonté
des participants c'est sûr que c'est un
mécanisme commun c'est la volonté des
participants l'attente de produire
quelque chose qui finalement produit
quelque chose l'attente produit la
manifestation mais quelle est la
mécanique derrière son on en a
absolument aucune idée le groupe D8 vont
se réunir pendant 5 ans ils vont même
faire des démonstrations à la télé on
pouvait introduire quelqu'un d'autre
dans le groupe ça fonctionnait aussi
mais ça devenait moins percutant plus
les gens avaient cette chimie entre eux
et dans le code Philippe ça a duré
pendant des années plus les le phénomène
les mécanismes de du phénomène se
produisait de manière volontaire et
spectaculaire l'expérience de Philippe a
l'avantage comme si souvent le
conscience d'être reproduisible donc
plusieurs groupes à travers le monde des
groupes de chercheurs en particulier ont
repris l'expérience de Philippe elle a
même été reprise ici même à Montréal on
avait inventé un homme du futur Alex qui
est encore une fois selon cette
biographie inventée la réaction de la
table après des mois en utilisant
toujours les mêmes participants la table
s'est mis à réagir ce que cette
recherche-là montre
on n'est pas encore dans le domaine de
la science parce que la science est plus
exigeante que ça mais ce que
l'expérience montre c'est qu'il est
possible que l'esprit affecte la matière
mais de quelle façon elle le fait
quelles sont les mécaniques qui
sous-tendent ça on en a strictement
aucune idée parce que il faut pas le
cacher l'expérience de Philippe si on
reconnaît l'authenticité de l'expérience
elle nous place dans une situation du
quasi impossible parce que pour deux
raisons lorsque la table bouge il faut
forcément de l'énergie notre monde
physique dont tel qu'on le connaît si un
mouvement il doit bien y avoir de
l'énergie on aime bien utiliser dans le
discours commun dans le discours de tous
les jours l'énergie psychique ça fait
beau de dire sur l'énergie psychique
mais récupérer la réalité l'énergie
psychique n'existe pas aussi elle existe
on l'a jamais vu on l'a jamais calibré
récemment dans une entrevue on parlait
avec des chercheurs du grand
collisionneur de hadron et l'un d'entre
eux dit lorsqu'on lui a posé la question
sur l'avenir psyché qui dit écoute on a
réussi à isoler le boisson de Higgs mais
l'énergie psychée donc c'est une énergie
ça fait bien de l'utiliser ça peut même
paraître un peu scientifique mais
techniquement parlant il y a aucun moyen
de savoir si l'énergie psychique elle
existe et encore moins de pouvoir la
documenter donc là on a une première
problématique
et la deuxième problématique dans le
code de la table de Philippe c'est que
les phénomènes paranormaux il s'est
peut-être une des raisons pourquoi il y
a un tel frein entre l'acceptation du
paranormal et le langage courant c'est
que les phénomènes paranormaux fleurs
avec le religieux quelqu'un qui dit je
communique avec un esprit ou un défunt
ou quelqu'un qui dit je communique avec
Jésus il Saint-Esprit on n'est pas loin
là ça se ressemble beaucoup à quelqu'un
qui croise pardon mais quelqu'un qui
croit la résurrection ou que Jésus
marchait sur l'eau c'est des phénomènes
paranormaux absolument donc quelqu'un
qui dit je suis allé à l'Oratoire
Saint-Joseph j'ai prié le frère André
j'ai été guéri donc c'est un phénomène
qui en dans le discours religion va
appeler un thaumaturge le frère André
est un thamasurge mais dans le discours
de tous les jours on va aller voir un
guérissant monsieur Maurice quelque part
dans le petit village lui fait des
touchés avec les mains et puis il me
semble qu'on sent beaucoup mieux et là
évidemment il y a tout le comité des
médecins qui font de la foutaise mais
pourtant entre le taux mature et le
guérisseur on est dans les mêmes zones
on n'utilise pas le même langage on est
dans les mêmes os et c'est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle la science est si
réservée par rapport aux paranormal
c'est qu'on flirte avec leur religieux
et la science n'aime pas le religieux
donc tant et aussi longtemps qu'on
arrivera pas avec des mesures
calibrables des mesures scientifiques
rigoureuses et une possibilité de
reproduction laboratoire les phénomènes
paranormaux vont avoir la vie dure parce
que la science qui n'aime pas la
religion et d'autant plus vigilante par
rapport à ces phénomènes mais
l'expérience de Philippe montre un peu
quelle est la mécanique peut-être
derrière l'épaule d'orgases
involontairement est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas un mécanisme dont ne connaît pas la
mécanique mais qui pourrait déclencher
des phénomènes physiques à partir d'une
attente ou de la volonté de produire
quelque chose mais encore une fois il
faut le dire la recherche en
parapsychologie a perdu un peu de son
lustre dans les années 60 et 70 ça a été
l'âge d'or de la parapsychologie elle
encore aujourd'hui elle se fait de
manière beaucoup plus souterraine à
cause peut-être de tous les illuminés du
paranormal qui ont qui ont spolié le nom
de parapsychologue et là les chasseurs
de fantômes qui deviennent un peu des
scienteux parce qu'ils utilisent des
appareils puis qui donne l'impression de
faire de la science et les milieux de la
parapsychologie sont très éloignés de ça
donc ils ne veulent pas trop se mettre
de l'avant et ne voudraient surtout pas
être associé à ces gens-là qui sont rien
d'autre que des fantaisistes c'est juste
par rapport à l'expérience de Philippe
les Connemara qu'on entendait ils sont
pas seulement subjectifs sont ils ont
été mesurés donc on était on avait placé
des micros sous la table sur la table et
la signature des coûts qui étaient
frappés provenaient de l'intérieur de la
table c'était ni un coup en dessous ni
un coup en sur le dessous en dessous
c'est vraiment un coup qui semblait
provenir de l'intérieur de la table et
qui est résonna à travers tout le
plateau on a toutes ces données là
l'expérience comme je l'ai mentionné
était reprise ailleurs avec à peu près
des résultats semblables bien sûr à
cette expérience là pendant des mois
sinon des années en sa demande un agenda
bien précis on a réussi à reproduire ces
phénomènes-là mais on a absolument si
demain matin quelqu'un vous dit je sais
comment ça fonctionne méfiez-vous la
science le sait pas on de tout les
amateurs les amateurs de surnaturels ont
tous une bonne explication pour
expliquer la télékinésie les fantômes et
tout le reste parce que le mot qui est
le plus galvaudé je pense dans l'univers
du paranormal c'est je vais démystifier
donc finalement le chasseur de fantômes
qui vous dit je vais démystifier les
manifestations que chez vous chez vous
vous n'avez pas des fantômes ou des
revenants vous avez des Shadows people
ok donc tu démystifies le mystère parce
que démystifier c'est enlever le mystère
tu enlèves le mystère
on est bien parti donc ce mot là il est
excessivement galvaudé mais faut faire
attention jusqu'à maintenant on sait pas
comment fonctionner l'expérience de
Philippe les capables de la reproduire
on
on dirait que ça rend ça c'est vraiment
de dire voici la limite de la science
voilà absolument voici où la science
n'est pas rendue encore de pouvoir nous
expliquer ce phénomène-là qui est
reproduisable ça va être absolument donc
c'est tout rangement on a le mode
d'emploi parce que les gens de l'équipe
du docteur Owen ont écrit un ouvrage qui
s'intitule country up Feld en français
c'est Philippe Le Fantôme imaginaire qui
était écrit par l'épouse du docteur Owen
qui était l'une des 8 personnes autour
de la table et aussi par Margaret Sparro
la directrice de Mansa Canada donc on
conjointement écrit cet ouvrage on a
toute la méthode on a tous les
paramètres on a toutes les informations
qui ont été colligées donc on peut
reproduire l'expérience mais sans pour
autant avancer une quelconque mécanique
notre problème c'est il faut qu'il y ait
une énergie cette énergie
malheureusement dit on ne la connait pas
on n'est pas capable de la domestiquer à
moins qu'il y ait d'autres mécaniques
dans la physique qui fait qu'un objet
pourrait bouger sans qu'il y ait un
d'énergie mais là on n'est pas dans on
est dans le domaine de la fantaisie
parce que si on réussit
il me semble que derrière cette
expérience là se cache une source de
connaissance incroyable c'était si on
apprend si on réussit à si on réussit à
apprendre que des esprits communs
peuvent s'allier pour créer une force
physique
ça ouvre la porte à beaucoup de choses
qu'on ignore et là tu soulèves un des
grands problèmes de la part psychologie
oublions
le paranormal populaire et populiste
celui qu'on rencontre au salon de
l'ésotérisme si on parle vraiment de la
recherche sur les phénomènes paranormaux
autour de ce fameux 5% qui qui nous
échappe encore la problématique c'est un
problème une problématique de recherche
les gens s'imaginent les gens idéalisent
les scientifiques comme étant des gens
qui recherchent la vérité avec un grand
V mais la réalité c'est pas ça les
scientifiques doivent d'abord chercher
du financement pour faire de la
recherche et les compagnies subsidèrent
les fournissent du financement à la
recherche scientifique ce sont
généralement des compagnies qui
éventuellement veulent empocher sur
l'investissement si on parle simplement
de développer un nouveau médicament à
Claire's de façon générale développer un
nouveau médicament c'est à peu près 800
millions de dollars si on tire une ligne
donc 800 millions on comprend que les
compagnies fizer du bon peu importe les
compagnies qui vont investir dans la
recherche veulent éventuellement des
retomber économiques sur
l'investissement bien sûr ils nous
dirons qu'ils ont une vision un peu
humaniste et tout le reste on l'a vu
avec la covid les compagnies s'en sont
mis plein les poches bien sûr la covid
était bien là puis les vaccins ont aidés
bon c'est la c'est le commerce c'est la
Business c'est le monde capitaliste donc
au niveau de la recherche on travaille
exactement dans le même domaine bien sûr
il y a un peu de sous qui est lancé dans
la recherche pure on va étudier
l'atmosphère de Vénus et tout le reste
donc là on n'a pas vraiment de retomber
court terme mais néanmoins on investit
dans cette recherche là mais
généralement les compagnies veulent une
retombée économique
alors je vais te donner un exemple assez
simple si demain matin deux
scientifiques de grands Renault un
chimiste et un physicien proposait deux
programmes différents le premier le
chimiste propose une recherche sur la
mousse verte sur les crottons et l'autre
propose une recherche sur les fantômes
ben je te garantis que c'est la
recherche sur la mousse verte c'est
crotons qui va être financé parce
qu'avec la mousse verte c'est crotons je
vais peut-être découvrir quelque chose
un nouveau médicament un vaccin et
éventuellement faire sonner les caisses
mais si je fais une recherche sur les
fantômes ça va donner quoi
éventuellement d'apprendre qu'une vie
après la mort que des mon grand-père
revient de l'au-delà on voit pas de
quelle façon on pourrait tirer profit
d'une telle recherche donc on va
préférer les compagnies subsidaires ont
préféré mettre des sous là où il y a une
possibilité de ne retomber économique à
court terme ou à moyen terme ou bien
dans de la recherche pure mais qui n'est
pas controversé personne va dire c'est
contreversé de chercher de la vie sur
Mars ou d'étudier l'atmosphère de Vénus
ou de savoir s'il y a une dixième
planète au-delà de Pluton puis de la
ceinture de Kuiper personne dit que
c'est controversé ça fait de la
recherche pure et on s'entend qu'il faut
financer pour le meilleur connaissance
humaine les fantômes tout ça c'est une
recherche contreversée et éventuellement
ça rapporte peu de sous aujourd'hui ça a
un peu changé au cours des années mais
il y a quelques années encore à peine
les gens qui s'intéressaient à la
recherche en paraps psychologie on parle
des milieux académiques parce que dans
les années 50 et 60 il faut se rappeler
que près il y avait dans le monde
occidental plus d'une cinquantaine
d'universités qui avaient ou bien des
départements de recherche en
parapsychologie ou qui était affilié à
des centres de recherche en
parapsychologie et la plupart de ces
centres là étaient dirigés par des gens
qui étaient soit des psychologues ou des
psychiatres qui avaient une formation
sur la parade psychologie la parole
psychologie d'ailleurs qui est un
mauvais nom qui veut dire aux côtés de
la psychologie alors qu'on préférait
dans le milieu parler de la psychologie
absy 23e lettre de l'alphabet grec qui
ce sont des phénomènes anormal ou
anormales on préfère le terme anomal qui
est moins dur que anormal c'est
simplement des phénomènes qui sortent de
la normalité et on avait donc 50
000 de laboratoires dans le monde
occidental qui s'intéressent à ces
sujets-là qui étaient bien financés et
puis éventuellement tout ça diminué et à
un moment donné à partir des années 70
le milieu des années 80 quand tout ça
s'est arrêté on avait à peu près un
budget annuel d'un million de dollars
que tous ces gens-là se partager
ensemble donc une fois que tu avais payé
ton téléphone ton loyer ben il est resté
plus de sous pour faire de la recherche
ces dernières années de son cours des 10
dernières années bon quelques mécènes
sont décédées ils ont donné des sommes
d'argent considérables qui permettent de
que donner un second élan à la recherche
en parapsychologie mais ça reste un
milieu qui est très marginal
et ce qui est très malheureux c'est un
peu le travail que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est que ces gens-là font du travail
qui remarquables il publie dans des
périodices scientifiques avec des
comités de lecture mais souvent bien sûr
le c'est des magazines qui sont
anglophones pour la plupart ce sont des
périodiques scientifiques donc coûteux
et les abonnements sont très coûteux et
souvent le discours est très hermétique
qui s'adresse pas à monsieur et madame
tout le monde et il n'y a pas de
courroie de transmission donc qui lit
les périodiques scientifiques d'autres
scientifiques des gens d'une ligne
certaine élite et l'information circule
dans ce milieu-là et eux ces gens-là ils
sont 10 ans en avance sur nous mais il y
a pas de courroie de transmission
publique donc on est encore aujourd'hui
l'homme de la rue croit encore que les
fantômes c'est ce qu'il voit à la télé
avec des tables qui bougent soit ris
surnaturelle où on capte des fantômes
qui parlent sur des détecteurs de champs
électromagnétiques c'est un peu ridicule
tout ça et c'est dépassé on en est plus
là en paraps psychologie mais c'est le
milieu populaire et populiste parce
qu'il n'y a pas de courroie de
transmission qui des milieux de la
recherche pure sur ces phénomènes vers
monsieur et madame tout le monde
je pense que je suis seul
quelque chose que les gens doivent
retenir c'est ce que vous voyez à la
télé ce que vous entendez le discours de
ce paranormal populaire n'est pas ce qui
se fait dans les milieux de la recherche
en sciences on est beaucoup plus loin
que ça et tout ça c'est un peu ridicule
c'est de la quincaillerie c'est du
divertissement on va voir comme ça puis
en fait c'est c'est fascinant de le voir
comme ça parce que tu mettes on parle on
a reçu des gens par exemple je veux
prendre juste cet exemple là qui sont
venus parler de physique quantique ici
et puis
notre perception du public général de ce
qu'est la physique quantique est loin de
Westie réellement c'est fascinant de
voir le paranormal puis la parade
psychologie comme quelque chose de même
aussi c'est où est-ce que nous on a on
joue au widget chez nous puis on n'est
pas capable de comprendre qu'est-ce qui
se passe au widget alors qu'il y a des
groupes de scientifiques qui ont fait
précisément c'est quoi le 8e histoire de
Philips c'est du widgel en fait il y a
deux éléments qui tiennent le manger qui
sont très intéressants d'abord la
physique quantique t'amusant parce que
le paranormal va le paranormal populaire
et populiste il va s'inspirer de ce qui
se fait dans des domaines d'assurance
donc la physique quantique personne
comprend comment ça marche même nous on
en a parlé pendant une heure et demie
puis encore là mystérieux et là on voit
que les milieux du paranormal récupèrent
la physique quantique
c'est difficile c'est quoi l'énergie
pour pousser une tasse physique
quantique
comme l'explication on soit physique
coincé voilà la physique quantique va
tout expliquer tout donc ça c'est un peu
c'est un peu ridicule donc on récupère
ça et l'autre élément tu dois mentionner
le 8 juin mais tu vois entre le widget
populaire on se réunit un groupe d'amis
on utilise le widget pour essayer de
contacter les défunts il y a certains il
y a ça qu'on voit à la télé qu'on parle
beaucoup mais combien des gens qui nous
écoutent aujourd'hui savent que pendant
deux ans l'Université de la
Colombie-Britannique l'univers avant
couvert on fait de la recherche sur le
widget non non les conditions
rigoureuses qu'en est-il le résultat
était spectaculaire
je vais essayer si vous me permettez de
résumer en quelques minutes ce qu'on a
fait c'est qu'on s'est dit on va d'abord
prendre des gens de sélectionner des
gens attelage donc des gens du public
sans connaissance particulière c'était
simplement des questions générales donc
on a posé ces gens-là des questions avec
c'était oui ou non donc est-ce que
thalassi est la capitale de la Floride
c'est oui ou non les gens non mais ça
c'est important donc tu vois donc
c'était simplement des questions
généralistes et bien sûr dans un grand
échantillonnage j'aurais à peu près 1000
personnes comme on posait des questions
qu'elle est dans tous les sens
géographie sciences bon la vie
quotidienne politique on s'est retrouvé
avec une moyenne d'à peu près 50% ce qui
était les normes du hasard puisque ta
réponse est oui ou c'est non mais une
fois une chance sur deux de tomber sur
la bonne réponse si tu la sais pas donc
on avait à peu près une moyenne de 50%.
on a pris ensuite ces gens là puis là je
vais essayer de schématiser c'était plus
complexe que ça la mécanique mais grosso
modo on a dit aux gens ok parfait
maintenant on a répondu à ça on va faire
un autre test exactement semblable avec
un autre groupe de gens question
généraliste
on les a amené dans une pièce et on dit
là cette fois vous allez être jumelé
avec quelqu'un et un jeu widget donc la
personne rentre dans laboratoire elle
voit devant lui un laborantin la planche
widget vont lui et là on lui bande les
yeux et on place ses doigts sur le temps
qui visualise bien la planchette le oui
est à droite le nom est à gauche donc il
visualise la planchette on lui bande les
yeux on place ses doigts sur le mobile
et lui bien sûr il a l'impression où il
croit que le laborantin devant lui fait
exactement la même chose alors qu'en
réalité le laborantin reste debout de la
table il ne possédois sur le widget et
on a repris l'expérience en posant ces
gens-là des questions de façon générale
est-ce que tu allais assis la capitale
de la Floride etc on pose des questions
et on était surpris de voir que les gens
les yeux bandés les mains sur le widget
ont répondu avec un taux de précision
plus élevé que le hasard en fait ils ont
répondu à un niveau qui est défi le
simple hasard on parle par exemple de
60% donc une variante de 10%, comment
l'expliquer cette variante là en fait le
bruit de John nous montre de manière
inconsciente qu'on s'est beaucoup plus
de choses sans filtre on s'est beaucoup
plus de choses qu'on croit le savoir
donc si je te pose la question est-ce
que tu as assez la capitale de la
Floride d'un rotondance à dire oui et là
tout d'un coup tu te mets un filtre
t'aime pas et là soudainement le doute
se construit mais notre invité qui avait
les doigts sur le widget lui allait à
gauche ou à droite y aller là où le
Widget or c'était son inconscient qui
poussait vers le Oui ou vers le nom et
l'expérience widget montre que de
manière inconsciente on s'est beaucoup
plus de choses si on sait quand
l'expression de j'aurais dû écouter ma
première voix ou ma première impression
mais c'est souvent cette inconscient qui
nous parle donc le cumulatif de toute
une série d'informations qui dès qu'on
commence à mettre un filtre on sème le
doute alors que dans le cas du widget
les gens y de manière spontanée donc le
widget n'a pas révélé qu'on parlait avec
les esprits mais le montrer que de
manière inconsciente on s'est peut-être
plus de choses qu'on croit le savoir et
l'expérience du widget est
extraordinaire et non je vous rassure
messieurs l'Université de la
Colombie-Britannique avant couverts
pour aller chercher cette information de
manière inconsciente mais ça personne ne
parle de ça on parle du médium on parle
pas de cette expérience là qui est
extraordinaire récemment je parlais à
des gens je disais est-ce que vous avez
des gens entendu parler de
l'embouteillage visuel la personne
entend tu parler de ça et pourtant dans
les recherches sur les sens cognitif
c'est un élément marquant qui est très
important pour comprendre les phénomènes
paranormaux
si on peint monsieur et madame tout le
monde de manière générale dans un
environnement qui nous est familier
notre œil enregistre à peu près 60
images à la seconde ces images-là sont
envoyées dans notre dans notre cortex
visuel et notre cerveau va décanter
l'information donc dans un environnement
qui nous est familier on voit un chat
passé donc notre cerveau voit l'image du
chat qui avance envoie l'information et
là notre cerveau dit ok un animal à
quatre fois à quatre pattes avec une
cuve des oreilles pointues c'est un chat
ok on passe à la prochaine image et donc
on fait ça
ça c'est dans la mesure où ce que l'on
voit ou l'environnement dans lequel on
se trouve nous est familier mais à
partir du moment où ce que l'on voit ou
ce que l'on perçoit ne fait plus partie
de notre quotidien notre cerveau mais
plus de temps à décanter l'information
donc il reçoit l'oeil lui continue de
voir 60 images à la seconde mais quand
les images arrivent au cerveau le
cerveau mais plus de temps donc il va
peut-être décanter une image sur deux
une image sur 5 mais que fait-il des
autres humains il les élimine il les
garde pas pour les décanter par la suite
ils les élimine dans ici bien que c'est
comme si je regardais un film la réalité
que je vois lorsque je me retrouve dans
un environnement qui ne met pas familier
ou que je vois quelque chose qui ne
m'est pas familier c'est comme si je
prenais un film et je retirais trois ou
quatre images toutes les trois secondes
ou les quatre secondes à la fin je me
retrouve avec un film qui me raconte une
autre histoire que sa véritable histoire
et ça c'est extraordinaire parce que ça
nous montre
quand on dit par exemple dans une maison
hantée ou qu'on voit un ovni on est
généralement dans un environnement qui
nous est en familier donc on se retrouve
c'est la nuit on est à l'extérieur en
voiture on voit quelque chose dans le
ciel regarde mais qu'est-ce que c'est et
le temps que notre cerveau qu'on reçoit
les images on essaie de les décanter il
y a peut-être au côté de cette grosse
lumière blanche il y a peut-être une
petite lumière verte une petite lumière
rouge mais mon cerveau ne les enregistre
pas et au moment où je vais raconter
l'histoire au moment de restituer
l'histoire je vais dire il y avait une
lumière blanche et je suis certain qu'il
n'y avait pas de lumière rouge ou de
lumière verte qui aurait pu me laisser
croire que c'est un avion et pourtant
elles étaient là c'est simplement que
mon cerveau ne les a pas enregistré
c'est exactement la même chose avec les
maisons hantées je me retrouve dans un
environnement bien souvent on me dit
c'est une maison hantée de ça donc il y
a une espèce d'attente qui pourrait y
avoir quelque chose et là soudainement
une porte se ferme
ce que mon cerveau enregistré parce que
j'étais dans un contexte particulier
c'est qu'il y avait un courant d'air la
fenêtre de qui était dans la pièce d'à
côté était ouverte mais je ne l'ai pas
vu où j'ai la certitude qu'elle était
fermée et je recrée la réalité telle que
mon cerveau l'enregistré c'est cette
vérité psychologique qui parfois est
très différente de la vérité factuelle
mais à cause de cette embouteillage
visuel il y a plein d'informations qui
misent de côté dès qu'on se retrouve
dans une situation inhabituelle mais son
en parle jamais les chasseurs de
fantômes préfèrent nous endormir avec
c'est l'esprit de Jean-Paul qui vont se
manifester puis
OK parfait et moi c'est drôle parce que
excusez-moi de vous interrompre je parle
mais je trouve fascinant cette idée
d'expliquer le paranormal en allant vers
ses côtés là qui sont un peu méconnus de
nos sciences cognitives ça nous apprend
beaucoup sur ce que l'on est et comment
on perçoit l'environnement autour de
nous on oublie souvent que l'être humain
en deux se reproduire et vivre c'est les
deux seules fonctions et à partir du
moment où je me reproduis ben je peux
mourir et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
on s'étonne un peu mais plus on note
population vieillit autrefois on mourait
on se reproduisait pas 40 ans on était
mort aujourd'hui la médecine nous permet
de vivre jusqu'à 90 ans mais on voit
qu'à partir de 50 il y a des maladies on
voit que physiquement notre corps de la
difficulté à
perdurer toutes ces années parce que ce
sont les mécaniques la mécanique de la
nature mon cerveau lui n'a que deux
fonctions me garder en vie et de
s'assurer je vais me reproduire c'est
c'est le leitmotiv de tout espèce
vivante donc la réalité autour de moi
elle devient secondaire donc
le phénomène de fantôme que j'ai vu la
porte qui s'est ouverte mon cerveau n'en
n'a rien à cirer de ce dont il me
restitue la réalité dans la mesure où ma
vie n'est pas menacée c'est ce qu'il
fait est-ce que ma vie étant danger non
bon donc il peut jouer sur la réalité
dès qu'il me transmet c'est sans
conséquences pour lui mais ça le met
tout ça aura une conséquence dans mon
discours et c'est comme ça qu'on crée
des univers qui sont un peu fantasmés
donc un moment donné
il faut sortir du pays d'aller sous le
pays des merveilles et regarder ce qui
se fait dans la réalité j'espère que je
vous embête pas tout le monde
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est souvent
ces expériences-là subjectives qui sont
à la base de tous ces mythes-là parce
que on peut vivre des expériences puis
comme tu disais tantôt tu sais des gens
qui disent moi j'ai vécu une expérience
surnaturelle ça paraît tellement réel
que il y a aucun doute dans ton dans mon
esprit que c'est vrai si moi mettons
pour donner un exemple quand j'étais
jeune je me souviens très bien il y a
une nuit j'étais dans mon lit puis que
je me souviens très bien le voir le
fantôme de voir la madame tournoyer dans
dans haut de ma chambre il me disait
qu'on était dans sa maison puis qui
était forgé qu'on soit le petit puis je
me souviens avoir raconté ça [ __ ] moi
mettons moi je viens beaucoup plus de la
perspective sceptique que de croyant au
paranormal
je faisais Parlement un cauchemar
j'étais entre l'éveil puis le sommeil où
j'étais peut-être en état de
elle dit du sommeil chose comme ça tu
sais puis j'ai imaginé ça mon cerveau à
projeter ça puis et puis quand je
raconte ça des gens qui sont plutôt
porté à toi au paranormal mais c'est
évident que
pour ces gens-là c'est comme puis
justement je pense que c'est quand même
au final plutôt fréquent que notre
cerveau va nous jouer des tours ou qu'on
va vivre ou qu'on va être témoin de
quelque chose qui est réellement
l'homme et qui inexplicable puis j'ai
l'impression qu'aussi une autre faille
de notre cerveau c'est qu'on a beaucoup
de misère avec
l'inconnu puis le vide puis il est
expliqué on va toujours trouver depuis
le début de l'humain on savait pas
c'était quoi le soleil la lune c'était
les dieux puis on a toujours rempli le
vide de l'inconnu par des réponses qu'on
s'inventées parce qu'on avait de la
misère à dîner avec cette inconnue
l'homme est fondamentalement un être
croyant donc on a besoin de croire en
toute sorte de choses puis l'idée que
notre le monde laquelle on vit est
enchanté un peu magique ça fait norme
c'est normal ça fait partie de l'être
humain donc dans des phénomènes lorsque
les gens rapportent des trucs un peu
étranges et bizarres moi je peux dire
après 46 ans passer dans cet univers là
que les gens nous montrent rarement les
gens lorsqu'ils racontent l'expérience
il raconte ce qu'il croit
fondamentalement avoir observé ou ce
qu'ils ont vécu c'est notre
interprétation qui est qui est énorme
des gens vont aller vers le revenant
d'autres vont aller vers une explication
plus prosaïque plus scientifique et en
même temps on dit souvent nous voulons
la vérité je vis en expérience par
anormale tu en parles je veux la vérité
mais en réalité bien souvent on cherche
un biais de confirmation on veut que les
gens nous disent ben ton véhicule
expérience vraiment paranormale et en
même temps c'est aussi le propre de
l'être humain de ne jamais se mettre en
cause lui-même c'est toujours la faute
de l'autre c'est la transcendance c'est
pas moi c'est l'autre donc si je suis
dans mon lit et je vois un phénomène
paranormal on se réveille la nuit on ne
l'impression que quelqu'un côté de notre
lit un scientifique zéro vous savez il
existe à peu près 200 parasomnies donc
200 troubles du sommeil qui peuvent nous
amener à des terreurs nocturnes à
paralysie du sommeil les hallucinations
le cauchemar réveillé donc tous ces
éléments-là peuvent affecter notre
perception mais encore une fois c'est le
propre de l'être humain de dire non
c'est pas moi c'est pas mes sens qui
sont mises qui sont mis en cause c'est
l'extérieur ça doit venir de l'autre et
l'autre c'est le fantôme c'est les
extraterrestres et c'est tout le reste
on voit ici non seulement des mécanismes
de perception mais on voit des
mécanismes également qui répondent à ce
que nous sommes intrinsèquement donc des
êtres croyants et on a tendance à être
avoir une je dirais une confiance
exagérée sur notre perception donc c'est
toujours les autres qui sont dans qui
qui produisent ce que l'on observe ou ce
qui se produit autour de nous donc tout
ça il faut en tenir compte puis qu'on
discute avec les gens qui ont vécu des
expériences normale il faut respecter
que ces gens-là croient parce qu'il y
aura fondamentalement
c'est une expérience tempéré sauf que
l'expérience empirique n'est pas une
preuve scientifique souvent les gens
disent ça moi combien de fois des gens
m'ont dit qu'il me connaissent pas très
bien il me dit si vous auriez vécu un
phénomène par anormal monsieur page vous
y croire
non j'en ai vécu quelques-uns pour
lesquels j'ai pas trouvé d'explication
et ça ne m'a jamais forcé à accepter les
extraterrestres ou accepter les fantômes
je pense que j'ai été peut-être abusé
par mes sens voilà je vais chercher
davantage de ce côté-là que du côté du
fantôme mais je respecte les gens qui
vont dire ben voilà ce sont des fantômes
en même temps on n'a pas la preuve
scientifique de là ou de l'autre
c'est-à-dire c'est plutôt une mécanisme
c'est plutôt une comment je me sens à
l'aise moi personnellement ça me parle
de fantôme je me sens beaucoup plus à
l'aise d'essayer de chercher une
explication scientifique alors que
d'autres sont plus portés vers des
explications mystiques ou ésotérique
mais dans un cas comme dans l'autre on
finale
donc il faut respecter ces positions
mais juste le fait que tu
que l'humain était
un humain en état de psychose va voir
des choses puis je peux voir quelque
chose qui est là puis être aussi certain
qu'ils réel que toi devant moi le type
puis ou sous l'effet de drogue
hallucinogène ce avoir des divisions
factures c'est pas en partant de le
c'est comme on sait pour un fait que on
est capable sous l'influence de soit de
troubles ou de substances ou peu importe
de voir des choses dans les moments
c'est pour ça qu'on écrit est-ce que tu
dis est intéressant non et c'est
intéressant parce que c'est exactement
le discours de la science c'est-à-dire
comme par exemple tu parles des drogues
psychotropes bon dans le domaine de la
recherche scientifique on a constaté que
certaines drogues psychotropes
permettaient de vivre des expériences
assez proches des expériences de mort
imminente et on sait que certains
certaines de ces psychotropes peuvent
être liés à des
neurotoxines que notre Cerba des
neurotoxines que notre cerveau va lancer
dans notre organisme donc à un moment
donné tu dis est-ce que quelqu'un en
état de mort imminente par exemple un
accident de voiture la personne se
trouve dans un état parce que la mort
c'est en fait c'est un processus c'est
pour certains ça arrive en une fraction
de seconde mais souvent le processus
peut prendre quelques secondes ou
quelques minutes donc lorsqu'on est dans
un processus de mort est-ce que notre
cerveau n'est pas conscient que nous
sommes en état de choc et va dorer la
pilule à rendre plus acceptable que
c'est la finalité et nous amener à cette
idée que oh je me sens bien je vois de
la lumière bon et on sait que des
drogues psychotropes sont capables de
produire ces effets-là donc au moment où
on parle et c'est ça qui malheureuse
parce que on est il y a le paranormal
scientifique et le paranormal populaire
le paranormal populaire c'est
immédiatement non c'est une vie après la
mort mais en réalité on le sait pas il y
a dans la communauté scientifique des
chercheurs qui croient que notre cerveau
pourrait produire de telles effets et
d'autres qui croient qu'il y aurait des
des éléments chimiques de notre cerveau
pourraient produire donc le débat il est
sain et il a lieu en ce moment mais on
est loin de ce qu'on entend dans l'homme
dans le discours de l'homme de la rue
au final la conclusion pour l'instant
c'est on ne sait pas effectivement qui
avancerait de dire non c'est sûr que
c'est une ville après la mort c'est sûr
que c'est ici c'est ça ben
automatiquement dans l'erreur
on peut pas personne peut arriver puis
prendre une position dire c'est c'est
définitif c'est ça qui se produit on le
sait pas encore il y a un discours qui
se tient un discours qui se fait c'est
la même chose avec les fantômes est-ce
que les revenants existent il y a des
phénomènes qui sont très intrigants pour
lesquels on a une bonne documentation
mais on comprend pas tout mais il faut
donner une chance à la science la
science ne s'est pas peut-être tout non
plus là c'est la science évolue il y a
des on se rend pas compte on a toujours
l'impression qu'on est dans une science
absolue on a l'impression que la science
de 2022 c'est la science absolue mais
comme grands-parents en 1960 croyac qui
vivait dans un monde où la science était
absolue donc
se rappeler que la science pour le
moment elle n'est jamais absolue elle
reste des choses à découvrir et ces
phénomènes-là font peut-être sont
peut-être la science de demain mais il
faut aussi accepter que des gens voient
dans ces phénomènes-là une forme une
intervention surnaturelle divine
mystérieuse puis en même temps il faut
il faut accepter ça avec
bienveillance les gens nous racontent
une expérience on écoute avec
bienveillance qu'il raconte sans pour
autant pouvoir trancher de manière
définitive ce qui est malheureux dans le
domaine du paranormal
et je sais que je parle beaucoup là
dans le domaine du paranormal c'est que
et c'est peut-être bon est-ce que c'est
la covid est-ce que ce sont les médias
sociaux mais on dirait qu'on a moins un
vieux monsieur là mais je me rappelle
dans les années 70 ou les années 80
quand on à l'époque on s'intéressait au
paranormal on avait bien sûr des
extrémistes sceptiques on avait des
extrémistes croyants mais on avait une
part de gens qui étaient partagés du
genre on le sait pas et on pouvait se
réunir discuter et changer et puis on le
faisait avec bonhomie on le faisait dans
un sentiment de de bienveillance et on
échange et même si on n'était pas
d'accord forcément avec notre vis-à-vis
et aujourd'hui c'est réunions long à peu
près disparu on a l'impression que les
gens dans cet univers-là se sont
polarisés les discours qui sont
polarisés et aujourd'hui il y a plus de
place à la discussion on a des sites de
gens qui crochent ovnis aux
extraterrestres d'autres qui fantômes
mais si vous intervenez dans l'une ou
l'autre de ces tribunes en disant ben
vous savez l'expérience qui a été menée
bah alors c'est immédiatement on va vous
rejeter vous allez être bon vous allez
être flashé toutes ces expressions parce
qu'on veut pas discuter de ça de
mentionner les expériences qui se
faisaient comment notre cerveau perçoit
la réalité une expérience qui a été
menée tout récemment par un type qui
s'appelle Olaf Blanque voilà blanc qui
le directeur du département de Recherche
en neurologie de l'Institut
polytechnique internationale de Lausanne
en Suisse relève blanche ce qu'il a fait
il a pris des gens qui souffrait
légèrement de
d'épilepsie pourquoi légèrement
d'épilepsie parce que les gens qui ont
cette pathologie présentent un état
assez semblable à monsieur et madame
tout le monde en état de fatigue donc
moi quand je suis fatigué vous messieurs
quand vous êtes fatigués ben on présente
une pathologie qui est voisine des gens
qui souffrent très légèrement
d'épilepsie donc au lave blanc compris
ces gens là les amener dans son
laboratoire
on les a bandés les yeux et on les
opposait devant eux ils avaient un
espèce de bras articulé qui ressemble un
peu au bras qui soutient notre micro et
sans studio et ces gens-là devaient avec
au moment où vous entendez un espèce de
bip ils avaient l'index placé comme sur
le bout du bras articulé quand ils
entendaient le bip il devait pousser sur
le bras articulé et au même moment où il
poussait dans leur dos un autre bras
articulé faisait exactement le même
mouvement et les touchettes dans le
milieu du dos donc la première fois le
type les yeux bandés dans le laboratoire
en tant que B puis pose sur le bras
articulé il est touché dans le dos au
début il y a une surprise ah mais quand
il leur fait cinq ou six fois mais il y
a compris c'était quoi la mécanique non
il pousse il se fait toucher dans le dos
au même moment et puis Olaf blanc a
différé le stimuli dorsale de quelques
fractions de seconde demi seconde
peut-être et à ce moment-là
[Musique]
on veut pas allumer de lumière à savoir
pourquoi les fantômes ne détestent dans
la lumière c'est une question un peu
étrange je me rappelle que je me
rappellerai toujours que mon grand-père
quand j'étais enfant nous disait dans le
noir tu peux te faire des accroches et
c'est tout à fait donc on va visiter des
maisons hantées dans l'obscurité on
n'allume pas de lumière souvent ces
gens-là le font de nuit
sous prétexte que il y a moins de bruit
à l'extérieur donc moins de pollution de
voiture qui circulent dans les rues tout
ça donc si on est en pleine nuit notre
cycle en particulier on est fatigué on
est la nuit il y a une attente on est
dans une maison hantée il doit y avoir
quelque chose qui va se poser donc tous
ces conditions là nous placent comme le
cobaye de la blanc dans son laboratoire
et soudainement j'entends un bruit un
stimuli je vois pas ce qui se passe et
j'ai l'impression que on a touché sur
l'épaule on a touché à la jambe c'est
toucher de fantômes alors que on a fait
une expérience qui montre bien ça je me
rappelle encore une fois c'était publié
dans des périodiques scientifiques je me
rappelle que l'un des titres étaient un
scientifique reproduit des fantômes en
laboratoire c'est un peu court je pense
que le phénomène
je pense que le phénomène des fantômes
est plus complexe que ça mais Olaf blanc
a mis un peu le pied dans la porte il
nous ouvre sur une perspective qui nous
montre que la science ne sait pas tout
qui a des bottes dans la mémoire et
qu'est-ce période de quel est le
dénominateur commun à toutes les
expériences paranormales le témoin c'est
le témoin donc il faut regarder le
témoin il est le moteur de notre vision
que l'on a du paranormal puis quelqu'un
qui croit au paranormal dure comme faire
ou qui croit au terrain du complot
d'avoir une discussion rationnelle puis
de faire changer d'avis cette
personne-là surtout quand on parle de
théories du complot
quand tu vas dire que tu es en désaccord
quand tu as donné des preuves inverse
c'est comme si ça nourrit encore plus le
complot parce que c'est tu veux c'est du
complot fait partie du complot mais
mettons qu'on se ramène ou Christian
pages de adolescent paranormal ça a été
quoi les étapes clés en fait comment
comment qu'on chavir de l'autre côté du
spectre finalement moi je te dirais que
au départ peut-être que j'étais
sceptique dans l'arme mais bon
évidemment projeté dans cet univers du
paranormal j'étais fasciné par ça mais
peu à peu
l'acquisition de connaissances
scientifiques mais surtout le mécanisme
du journalisme comment une information
est véhiculée est-ce qu'on peut
confirmer cette information l'importance
de retourner à l'élément de départ qui
raconte quoi à quel moment dans quel
contexte et dans le code du journalisme
on combien de fois on nous a répété une
nouvelle ne peut pas être traitée en
dehors de son contexte socio-économique
tu dois comprendre dans quel contexte
cette chose là se fait et cette
information là moi je ne l'avais pas
quand j'étais adolescent malheureusement
il faut pas se le cacher les gens de
cette tête du milieu du paranormal très
souvent sont ignorants en dehors de la
sphère qui les intéresse donc par
exemple les mois combien fois j'ai vu
des gens qui s'intéressent aux ovnis par
exemple et tout d'un coup tu lui dis oui
mais il y avait la guerre froide et là
il regarde avec des grands yeux mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que la guerre froide
comment peux-tu comprendre l'intérêt du
gouvernement américain pour des objets
volants non identifiés au milieu des
années 60 alors qu'il développait des
avions espions pour aller espionner la
Russie si tu sais pas ce qui était la
guerre froide il y a tout un contexte et
souvent on les gens sont incapables de
replacer ce contexte si on parle du
spiritisme pourquoi le spiritisme a-t-il
connu une telle popularité dans les 2e
moitié du 19e siècle jusque dans la
première moitié du 20e siècle ben parce
que un c'est une époque où il n'y a pas
de radio il y a pas de télévision les
gens se réunissent dans des salons et
soudainement il y a eu la guerre des
Bauer il y aura la première grande
guerre la guerre la Première Guerre
mondiale 14-18 et les gens veulent et il
y a bien sûr cet espoir d'une de plus en
plus on parle de la vie après la mort et
là soudainement des gens disent voilà
nous pouvons communiquer avec les
défunts donc il y a tout un contexte qui
fait que ces gens-là vont se réunir les
samedis soirs à la lumière d'une bougie
il y a pas de distraction à la télé pas
de distraction à la radio on veut garder
un contact avec un contact avec tous ces
gens qui sont décédés dans les guerres
fin du 19e début du 20e incluant la
Grande Guerre et le spiritisme va
trouver là-dedans un terreau fertile
pour s'exprimer donc tout ce contexte là
qu'on doit concevoir même la parade
psychologie repose au départ sur les
spiritisme on se rend pas compte à quel
point le spiritisme aura influencé la
recherche du paranormal au 20e siècle
d'abord lorsque les premiers chercheurs
ont commencé à s'intéresser aux
paranormal c'est d'abord et avant tout
grâce aux spiritisme avant au 19e siècle
au XIXe siècle 17e 18e siècle bien sûr
on entendait parler de ces histoires de
fantômes mais c'est intéressant peu les
scientifiques puis à l'époque c'est vrai
que la science côtoyait l'alchimie là
c'était pas encore très défini des
frontières mais à la fin du 19e siècle
en alors que ce produit aux portes c'est
l'air industriel qui commence l'air
scientifique et leur soudain ces gens
disent on peut communiquer avec les
revenants les tables bougent donc fait
apparaître des fantômes la première
démarche scientifique a été de
déterminer est-ce qu'on peut obtenir des
preuves valides de ces contacts avec
l'eau de l'homme peu à peu on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait énormément de
fraude à ça c'est joints bien sûr des
gens populaires comme Harry oudini que
livrer une véritable guerre contre le
spiritisme mais ça voulait pas dire
qu'on expliquait tout il y avait des
phénomènes qui étaient quand même
curieux et peu à peu une distance qui
s'est pris entre une communauté une
communauté de parapsychologue intéressé
par des phénomènes étranges et la
discussion avec les revenants mais la
parade psychologie est née d'un intérêt
premier pour le spiritisme donc il faut
comprendre tous ces mécanismes là pour
bien saisir de quoi on parle et
malheureusement dans le domaine du
paranormal les gens ont peu de
connaissances se sont souvent des gens
un peu
ignorants puis c'est vrai également que
c'est un phénomène qui est hors
académique il suffit d'avoir lu quatre
livres sur les ovnis pour se déclarer un
expert lire deux trois lits sur les
fantômes et voilà je suis
parapsychologue il y a pas de balises
les gens peuvent dire n'importe quoi
puis ça ne transmet que leur croyances
dans le milieu du paranormal je reviens
un peu à ta question qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on ne que j'ai basculé il y a comme
n'importe qui un mécanisme et quand on
en est pas conscient on a on en devient
la victime c'est un phénomène qu'on
appelle la dissonance cognitive mon
cerveau n'aime pas une information qui
est contraire à mes croyances et il
réagit le chimiquement il va envoyer le
des substances dans mon corps qui me dit
sac ton camp de là tu aimes pas ça c'est
comme si je venais de mordre dans un
morceau de citron et là mon cerveau me
dit tu as besoin d'une grosse cuillerée
dessus c'est un peu ça donc quand je
parle les liaisons dans le milieu du
paranormal ils croient au fantôme croise
extraterrestres dès que vous évoquez une
possibilité autre le cerveau réagit de
hausse je ne veux pas entendre ce
discours là ça c'est mordre dans un
morceau de citron vite amenez-moi du
sucre et donc il va se tourner vers des
gens qui un discours semblable aussi ça
c'est ce que je pourrais appeler notre
premier niveau mais il y a un deuxième
niveau tu l'as bien évoqué c'est le
milieu des complotistes des signes là on
est dans l'anti-chambre du fanatisme
religieux ce qui distingue les
complotistes c'est qu'ils ont tous
l'impression qu'ils font partie d'une
élite ils ont saisi quelque chose que
monsieur et madame tout le monde n'a pas
saisi il se regroupe en Dreux entre eux
ils se sentent privilégié de pouvoir
échanger entre certains formations et il
se donne presque un devoir apostolique
de convaincre les gens autour d'eux que
la menace est là qu'elle existe et bien
sûr ils sont complètement hermétiques à
toutes à tous discours différents s'il y
a un discours différent c'est qu'il est
fondamentalement un discours qui fait
partie du complot et là il y a un
dérapage sur lequel il y a aucun aucune
possibilité de revenir en arrière et là
c'est c'est comme quelqu'un qui est un
fanatique religieux qui a beau essayer
de discuter avec lui
aucune prise non c'est ça parce que il y
a un loupe qui va dans l'autre sens qui
est de
si tu proposes une alternative tu es
dans le complot contre qui qui favorise
leur prise de position du complot
en désaccord mais ce qui prouve cette
prouve qu'il supprime
les accords ça prouve encore plus ma
théorie tu fais pas t'en sortir de ça et
même si tu apportes des arguments qui
sont qui sont simples que tout le monde
peut comprendre il y a comme quelque
chose qui dérapant le bon sens des raps
et ça j'ai toujours eu un peu de la
difficulté avec ça je me rappelle quand
j'ai écrit un livre sur les théories du
complot et là c'est vrai qu'on glisse un
peu en dehors du paranormal mais dans le
cas des théories du complot j'essayais
d'appliquer la bonne logique du bon
journaliste qui vérifie une information
et il y avait un principe qui était
assez simple notamment lorsqu'on parlait
du World Trade Center
je disais oublions on a ici là autour de
la table on est on n'est pas forcément
déjà des spécialistes de l'aviation pas
des spécialistes des matériaux
spécialistes des explosifs du kérosène
mais allons vers quelque chose de
beaucoup plus simple pour faire une
un organisation comme celle-là donc
faire tomber des tours du World Trade
Center il faut une grosse organisation
parce qu'il faut falsifier des avions
falsifier les rapports radars il faut
que bon on a beau penser il y a un
missile qui a été lancé ça demande une
grande organisation puis des gens qui
vont aller poser des explosifs dans le
World Trade Center qui vont coordonner
leurs efforts pour que tout ça tombe en
même temps tout ça avec les avions qui
rentrent dedans donc combien de gens à
peu près on aurait eu besoin pour monter
un tel complot à la fois pour les tours
du World Trade Center le Pentagone est
bien sûr l'avion qui s'est écrasé
mettons le grosso modo ça essayons
d'être
d'être pessimiste la pizza 1000
personnes minimalement mille personnes
probablement plus parce que c'est
contrôleur aérien les faux documents les
mêmes mettons 1000 personnes je sais pas
dans quel monde vous vivez mais dans le
mien l'argent est très important et dans
ces 1000 personnes il y a personne qui
dit dans ces 1000 personnes l'événement
c'est en 2001 donc aujourd'hui on est 21
ans après les faits or on sait que
malheureusement une personne sur deux et
demi disons pour faciliter le discours
qu'une personne sur trois sera atteint
dans sa vie d'un cancer et 50% des gens
atteints d'un cancer vont décéder donc
si je prends qui avait 1000 personnes
qui ont pris par au complot du World
Trade Center aujourd'hui de ce nombre-là
il y en a au moins 32 qui sont décédés
d'un cancer et le cancer tu m'as pas de
ça du jour au lendemain là quand tu l'as
en 32 personnes sont décédées d'un
cancer donc ils ont eu un moment donné
un diagnostic final terminal et ces gens
là qui avaient peut-être de la famille
des enfants ces gens-là avaient un
secret qu'ils auraient pu monnayer pour
des millions de dollars
la personne en toute logique serait des
gants moi je vais mourir demain ça donne
quoi alors je vais vous dire voici les
gens qui étaient impliqués vous me
donnez 20 millions puis je vais
redistribuer ça ma famille c'est la
mécanique c'est simple on a même pas
réussi à garder l'identité secrète de
des troupes l'informateur du Watergate
alors si on a 1000 pilotes il y avait
qu'une personne débloquer personne on a
un million de 1000 personnes d'impliquer
et soudain pas une qui parle c'est
invraisemblable le bon sens des raps ici
obligatoirement après toutes ces années
le nombre de gens qui ont été impliqués
qui seraient décédé dans des
circonstances malheureuses aurait lâché
le morceau c'est ce qu'on appelle la
mécanique du secret tu peux pas regarder
un secret ad vitam eternam bien une
célèbre phrase d'Abraham Lincoln qui
disait on peut tromper une personne tout
le temps on peut tromper un petit groupe
de gens longtemps mais on peut pas
tromper tout le monde tout le temps et
c'est exactement ce qui se produit c'est
avec le World Trade Center après 21 ans
forcément des gens qui ont été impliqués
dans le complot aurait large le morceau
et en rapporter des preuves concluantes
et il y a dans le mécanisme journaliste
on le sait on l'a vu avec l'affaire Bill
Clinton et les cigares de la Maison
Blanche quand il commence à y avoir une
fuite je ne peux plus l'endiguer la
fuite devient rapidement un ruisseau le
ruisseau de rivière puis la rivière un
parent donc le monde se met à parler et
à partir de là tu peux plus arrêter ce
qui se produit dans le cas du World
Trade Center si quelqu'un avait parlé et
qui avait eu un fond à ça leur visseuse
et il y a une vision tout est amusant
parce que des théoriciens du complot
trouve tout le temps d'autres moyens
ouais mais là ils veulent pas les gens
veulent pas s'intéresser à ça ou non on
veut pas s'intéresser aux méchants
démocrate qui mangent des bébés dans des
pizzeria qui sont des satanistes ils
veulent pas s'intéresser à ça parce que
c'est dangereux
mais voyons c'est dangereux chaque année
il y a une centaine de journalistes
malheureusement qui sont assassinés à
travers le monde parce que ils ont voulu
couvrir le crime organiser un trafic
humain etc le trafic d'armes les
journalistes ils sont motivés par
l'information certains d'entre eux sont
un peu plus bécuniens voudraient avoir
le prix polyzer mais si on donne un
journaliste une information qui mérite
d'être travaillée il y aura toujours
preneur donc si des histoires comme
Culan c'est allé nulle part le World
Trade Center c'est aller nulle part bah
c'est parce qu'il n'y avait rien
derrière parce que sinon des
journalistes des journalistes sérieux
rigoureux ce serait intéressant
effectivement
j'avais une autre question
moi je voulais je voulais qu'on parle
puis là parce qu'on veut pas on veut pas
de garder à l'infini dernière question
rapide
parce que je trouve c'est super
intéressant surtout dans un contexte
nous deux on se connaît depuis
la cinquième année du primaire depuis
qu'on était tout petit puis il y a
justement entendu parler du du concept
de du souvenir qui se bonifie et puis
qui se modifie au furdre au fil du temps
où est-ce que les trucs sont racontés
nous on a des histoires qu'on raconte
systématiquement à chaque fois qu'on a
une soirée puis à chaque fois il y a
possiblement un petit détail qui change
ou est-ce que là l'histoire comment on
la raconte maintenant vers ce que ce qui
s'est passé à Shannon en sonde R3 on est
loin de la soirée exacte de comment ça
s'est passé sauf que notre souvenir il y
en ait pas moins clair et précis que
chaque élément qui viennent altérer le
souvenir devient un vrai souvenir donc
il y a pas j'ai pas ma version
d'aujourd'hui qui est différente j'ai
l'impression que la version que j'ai
donné il y a 20 ans et la même version
que j'ai donné aujourd'hui alors qu'en
fait des éléments ont changé mais ces
éléments là pris la place de d'autres
éléments donc la mémoire elle est
malléable il faut faire attention à ça
donc les gens qui nous racontent des
histoires bon j'ai vu un OVNI en 1962
une boule raconte alors voilà tu sais ça
fait quand même 60 ans de ça tu ok je me
questionner sur l'acuité du c'est
amusant parce que dans le domaine du
paranormal le témoignage est inaltérable
c'est le seul la seule la seule univers
où on accepte c'est son on va dans un
milieu on parle avec des avocats on
parle avec des policiers ils vont dire
le témoin me raconte une histoire
vieille de 30 ans tous ces gens-là vont
nous répondre un témoignage de 30 ans il
y a eu le temps de s'altérer sauf dans
l'univers du paranormal on a tous les
témoignages sont la même valeur toute la
même valeur que le témoignage date
d'hier ou qui date de 30 ans de témoin
oraison
le témoignage c'est ça la plus faible
valeur
faible de la chance puis juste pour
illustrer pour les gens qui nous
écoutent qui auraient pas eu la chance
d'entendre cette anecdote là
l'anecdote du souvenir modifié suite aux
lumières
la terrasse Bonaventure c'est ça
puis juste rapidement pour les gens qui
nous écoutent quelle forme ça peut
prendre parce que je sais qu'après il y
a des témoignages qui ont changé suite à
une reproduction télévisuelle de
l'événement
donc rappelons d'abord l'événement on
est le 7 novembre 1990 on est à Montréal
au centre-ville il y a des gens il faut
savoir que sur le toit de l'hôtel Hilton
Bonaventure aujourd'hui c'est seulement
l'hôtel Bonaventure ni plus avec la
chaîne Hilton mais à l'époque le Hilton
Bonaventure il y a une piscine sur la
terrasse qu'on peut utiliser
365 jours par année donc même en hiver
l'eau est chauffée et même un passage
qui nous permet de passer de l'intérieur
à l'extérieur donc ce soir là 7 novembre
une soirée assez agréable les gens sont
dans la piscine chauffée sur la terrasse
et enlevant les yeux vers le ciel il
voit ils vont décrire
au départ vers à peu près 19h il voit
une forme qui ressemble à une couronne
lumineuse 7 ou 8 lumières ambre avec des
faisceaux de lumière qui sont projetés
vers le sol donc on en informe la
sécurité et là éventuellement ça devient
le momentum et se demande de la sécurité
vont même téléphoner à la police de
Montréal qui va se rendre sur place les
policiers s'attendent à prendre une
déclaration mais lorsqu'ils arrivent sur
place ils constatent le phénomène il est
là il est à peu près statique tous les
témoins sont uneanimes il s'agit de
couronnes lumineuse elle a un peu bougé
de l'hôtel elle a bougé on a
l'impression qu'elle a bougé de du
bâtiment de la Bourse vers un peu la
place mon aventure mais c'est un arc le
1 degré dans le ciel c'est très minime
mais l'objet est statique là donc les
policiers sont là les éventuellement la
GRC va se rendre sur place le ciel étant
de législation fédérale donc on va
appeler la GRC et ces gens-là vont
observer le phénomène jusque peu à peu
le phénomène diminue en intensité et
vers 22 heures le a complètement disparu
donc évidemment ça alimente l'idée un
objet volant gigantesque immobile ou
déçu de la place
les témoignages m'ont tous dans le même
sens c'était une couronne lumineuse
couleur
ombre et statique et mobile
mais avec le temps bien sûr on parle
beaucoup de cette histoire là des gens
vont commencer à altérer des souvenirs
et je même sans m'en rendre compte je
vais je vais l'être un des éléments qui
vont contribuer à brouiller les cartes
au milieu des années 2000 c'était 2004
2005 à peu près on me demande de faire
une série d'aussi mystères pour Canal D
alors à ce moment-là on regarde des
événements que ce sont produits au
Canada principalement au Québec qui
serait mystérieux et l'incident de la
Place Bonaventure était l'un d'entre eux
donc on fait le reconstitution de ça et
pour ce qui est bon on est dans le
divertissement il faut mettre des trucs
qui sont assez fantastiques alors je
demande à mon bon ami Eric Nolin qui
fait également qui fait de la radio mais
qui fait également du trucage vidéo tout
ça qui fait un peu dans le cinéma je
demande à Eric est-ce que tu pourrais me
refaire une reconstitution de l'ovni
tout ça et
Eric je lui donne carte blanche puis il
va faire comme on dit là il y a beurré
épais il fait apparaître au-dessus de la
Place Bonaventure
petit circulaire avec des lumières tout
le tour puis des lumières bleues rouges
vertes qui clignote en dessous puis
l'objet tourne sur lui-même puis vient
glisser au-dessus de la place mon
aventure mais ça c'est de reconstitution
qui est très très lointaine de la
réalité là les gens parlaient simplement
de lumière en dans le ciel immobile
or après la diffusion de dossier mystère
en 2005 je m'aperçois que des gens vont
raconter qui était à l'hôtel bonne
aventure ce qui est bien possible mais
le soudain il ne parle plus de lumière
ambre statique en disant j'étais sur la
Place Bonaventure j'ai vu cet objet là
arrivé il était en circulaire et des
lumières bleues rouges en dessous qui
clignotaient donc le souvenir qu'il
raconte ni plus le souvenir de
l'événement mais c'est le souvenir de la
reconstitution qu'ils ont vu à la
télévision qui s'est soudainement
amalgamé avec leur témoignage et ça nous
montre à quel point le témoignage il est
fonction un de l'expérience elle-même
mais ensuite de ce que les gens diront
ce qu'ils vont raconter donc tous ces
éléments là qui vont être contribués à
plus facile témoignage il y a une
histoire similaire que j'ai entendu aux
États-Unis puis c'était probablement que
que tu la connais puis c'était deux gars
en fait que une nuit c'est-à-dire on va
jouer un tour ou à la ville ou village
puis ils ont fait de monter des ballons
puis qui
sauf que ça fait des lumières puis on va
appeler la radio locale puis on dit
regarder il y a de quoi de nexplicable
dans le ciel c'est vraiment bizarre je
pense que c'est des ovnis je pense que
c'est des
pour alimenter justement créer une
espèce d'événement
puis là c'était comme justement déjà des
lignes ouvertes de nuit c'est plus il y
a d'autres mondes aussi je vois ça bon
lendemain matin
il y a pas un petit peu dans les
nouvelles locales qui est événement
étrange cette nuit lumière dans le ciel
OK puis le plus le temps avance plus la
semaine avant c'était le plus en plus de
gens qui viennent raconter les
événements puis non mais moi j'ai vu ça
puis moi je l'ai vu là
se déplacer à 300 km/h puis moi j'ai
plus c'était de plus en plus farfelu
puis de plus en plus exagéré
puis à m'amener à apprendre bout de
temps mais là les deux gars qui avaient
un bon français un prank
on fait ben lui ça va prendre les
proportions ça devenait grosse affaire
là puis ça n'a parlé puis lui on en
prenait proportions qu'on peut prendre
ça on va le dire que c'est nous autres
exactement ils sont sortis puis on dit
ben non c'était juste une autre on a
fait de flamber du ballon pour pour
jointeau puis là ça commence à être trop
gros là les gens voulaient pas croire
non moi je sais ce que j'ai vu moi j'ai
vu ça je l'ai vu se déplacer puis j'ai
vu à la ferme où il est arrivé de moi
finalement puis finalement cette
histoire-là était inarrêtable même après
avoir dit non non c'était juste nous
autres dans le domaine du paranormal on
retrouve ça souvent ce genre de truc là
donc des gens qui ont falsifié de maison
hantée qui explique le canular mais on
ne veut pas croire ça je te donne un
exemple dans le domaine des ovnis on est
dans les années 90 fin des années 80
début des années 90 il y a une vague
d'OVNI sur la Belgique tout le monde
voit des objets étranges dans le ciel
puis c'est amusant parce qu'on voit
aussi le courant à l'époque il y a eu
les soucoupes volantes des années 70
ensuite les ovnis en Belgique les gens
disaient ressembler à des triangles là
tout le monde voyait des triangles et là
depuis quelques temps comme l'armée
américaine dit qu'ils ont vu un OVNI qui
ressemblait un tic-tac les gens se
mettent d'avoir des tic-tacs mais dans
le cas de des ovnis belge par exemple
les gens disaient c'est des objets des
triangulaires lumineux bah triangulaires
lumineux un avion dans le ciel les trois
lumières ressemblent des triangles là tu
sais bon tu as qu'à un moment donné un
type pour alimenter au travail a pris un
morceau de styromousse il y a mis trois
lumières dessus puis il la lançant en
l'air et puis il le prend en photo c'est
devenu la photo on l'appelait la photo
de Petit-Rechain donc le type a pris son
image il l'amenait à son à son travail à
l'usine puis l'afficher sur le sur le
babillard le tout le monde parlait de ça
éventuellement l'histoire est devenu
plus grande des gens ont commencé à
parler de ça d'un jour nous une photo
extraordinaire pétillant et là il y a
une organisation locale en Belgique la
sobex qui ont pris la photo ils l'ont
analysé en fait intervenir des experts
et là tous les experts étaient uneanimes
cette photo-là était extraordinaire la
façon dont les lumières étaient diffuses
aux extrémités ne pouvaient pas être un
flou à la photo c'était forcément de
l'énergie électromagnétique ça n'en
finissait plus et puis un moment donné
10 ans après l'effet le type en question
Patrick maréchal
sortie le diapo biberon
rouge lumière il y avait encore gardé la
maquette
les gens sont mais accusés le type
Patrick maréchal d'avoir truqué son
témoignage les gens préfèrent croire que
la photo de Petit-Rechain est réellement
un ovni triangulaire plutôt que le type
qui a avoué le canular et ça a été la
même chose probablement vous rappelez de
ça si vous êtes trop jeune mais au
milieu des années 90 il y a eu un
affaire de l'autopsie de
l'extraterrestre où on avait montré la
télé des images un soi-disant
extraterrestre qu'on avait capturé à
Roswell pour l'avait autopsie on a fait
plein d'émissions là-dessus claire la
marche a fait deux spéciales à la télé
pour parler de cette histoire là et
éventuellement le type c'est un coût
d'argent il l'expliquait d'une annonce
d'un mannequin en caoutchouc on l'a
ouvert non peut-être mais là les gens
non non il faut que c'est un coup monté
par le gouvernement se type là dites pas
vrai mais c'était vrai mais non que les
gens veulent croire encore écrit les
aveux de canular on veut croire à la
réalité d'un événement
c'est l'univers bienvenue dans l'univers
du paranormal mais c'est fascinant le
fait qu'il y a quand même des phénomènes
qu'on n'arrive pas à expliquer mérite
notre intérêt mais en même temps il faut
donner une bonne part à la science en
laisser de la science de la science
d'aujourd'hui n'a pas les réponses à
tout mais demain on verra ce que
j'ai pour dire que la science peut ou va
tout expliquer
puis souvent même la science lorsqu'elle
découvre des choses ça pose de nouvelles
de nouvelles questions on l'avait avec
la physique quantique on a on est arrivé
avec la physique quantique et la
physique quantique a ouvert de nouvelles
questions les recherches en astronomie
on place des télescopes on a passé de
hoball la James web on envoyait des
sondes sur Mars et les découvertes nous
amènent à nous poser de nouvelles
questions mettant en relief de nouveaux
phénomènes inexpliqués ou inexplicables
pour le moment mais faut-il dans 10 ans
dans 20 ans il faut repousser les
frontières de la connaissance humaine la
science c'est un consente évolution mais
quelque chose qui a fait ses preuves
c'est la méthode scientifique
et la perdure dans le temps on s'est
rendu compte qu'a fonctionnait donc
c'était pas un modèle parfait mais c'est
le modèle qui était le plus fertile
jusqu'à maintenant le modèle
scientifique c'est le modèle le plus
fictif donc même si il est pas parfait
donc il faut le conserver face à
justement une expérience comme ça
c'était d'essayer d'être capable de le
démontrer par cette méthode là ça va
vous faire un tri quand même absolument
je voulais là je pense qu'on est plus de
temps là on a quand même dépassé déjà là
qui ont constaté dit j'aurais voulu
juste vous le faire un segment en rafale
de vous poser des c'est à vous encore
on a parlé du World Trade Center
je me demandais et puis là essayons
justement de passer d'une à l'autre
rapidement mais je me demandais si
certaines des théories du complot les
plus célèbres mettons
de savoir pourquoi peut-être ça tient
pas la route ou d'où ça vient ou tu sais
tout ça enfin que je vous en lance une
coupe tu vois
ce d'où ça vient pour qu'on pense qu'il
est devenues puis pourquoi que pourquoi
que c'est possible elle existe bel et
bien c'est au départ la zone a été
construite dans les années 50 c'est un
consortium entre l'orchide l'armée
américaine et la CIA c'était ça avait
servi durant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
comme un lieu d'entraînement il y avait
quelques baraquements et puis dans les
années 50 on a rénové les endroits on a
rebbitonné les pistes et l'idée était de
développer un avion espion c'est là
qu'on a développé l'avion U2 en 1954 et
ensuite on a passé avec le SR71
Blackbird d'autres avions la technologie
des avions furtifs donc c'est un endroit
de développement
ultra secret de l'armée américaine pour
le comprendre c'est la force de la force
les forces américaines comme n'importe
quelle force militaire joue sur le
secret de leur armement c'est un peu
l'effet de surprise et dans les années
80 en 1989 un individu a un mental en
fait un menteur pathologique type qui
s'appelle Robert Lazare a raconté qu'il
avait travaillé dans cette base
la base ne fait aucun doute elle existe
on développe des avions et ce type là
encore en 89 dit voilà moi j'ai
travaillé quelques mois sur cette base
militaire d'Arey of the one en fait pas
nécessairement pas directement à la base
il dit qu'il y avait une dépendance de
l'autre côté de la montagne qui est à
papouzelec un secteur qui dit qui
s'appelait S4 il dit là il y a des
hangars qui étaient creusés dans la
montagne puis j'ai travaillé il y avait
9 soucoupes volantes moi j'ai travaillé
sur l'une d'entre elles l'idée était de
faire de la rétroingénierie donc on
comportait
des engins d'origine extraterrestre bon
et à partir de là évidemment les
les amateurs devenus ont sauté là-dessus
théorie un peu du complot c'est
fantastique on a des soucoupes volants
ça s'inscrivait également dans une
pensée depuis les années 50 les
Américains croient que beaucoup d'entre
eux croient que le gouvernement c'est
plus sur les ovnis qu'il n'en dit que
peut-être même qu'on aurait on aurait
récupéré des engins et accidentés comme
à Roswell tout ça donc ça s'inscrivait
dans une espèce de folklore populaire et
ce laser ne faisait que confirmer ces
éléments-là mais la problématique de
Lazare c'est dès qu'on vérifie un peu
ces allégations tout tombe les unes
derrière les autres et pour accepter ce
qu'il raconte faut mettre du complot
dans le complot qui par le complot à un
moment donné tu peux pas faire ça le
c'est pas de Lazare qui dit bon voilà
c'est un génial je suis diplômé de la
qualité et des diplômés également du MIT
tu peux pas être diplômé de la qualité
qui est du MIT en même temps ça se peut
pas ça ensuite quand on vérifie les
registres il est enregistré mis à l'une
ni à la société
jamais tes membres d'aucune photo de
finissant
personne se rappelle de lui et avant de
devenir ingénieur à la zone 51 il y a du
travailler ingénieur quelque part il
devrait être membre d'une association
d'ingénieurs avant de non on trouve pas
ça non plus il m'a encore effacé donc ça
devient une absurdité et là pour croire
ça c'est de rendre les services de
renseignement
omniscient ils sont capables de tout
d'effacer en quasiment un stylo effacer
ta mémoire et là c'est comme c'est
ridicule et continue de croire ça écoute
c'est encore une fois c'est la
dissonance cognitive d'abord plus ces
arguments là sont contredis puis on
préfère croire Robert la Robert Bob
Lazare plutôt qu'une réalité qui est le
type nous a menti nous raconte des
bobards depuis les années 50 les gens il
y a réussi un test de polygraphe mais
peut-être Bondy aussi
des peintures en série
posez-vous la question pourquoi le test
du polygraphe n'est-il pas admis devant
les tribunaux parce que de 40 ans il y a
des gens des bons menteurs qui
réussissent à traverser le test du
polygraphe il y a même des trucs pour
pouvoir passer du polygraphe
la même américaine comme diffusé
déclassifié des vidéos des vidéos
d'ovnis et puis tout le monde qui qui
qui projette là dedans des des
extraterrestres tout seul on fait on a
fait les amateurs de venir elle fait
beaucoup de kilomètres je suis pas grand
chose d'abord ça commence en 2017 il y a
une information qui est de qualité là
quand même en 2017 le New York Times
nous apprend que le gouvernement
américain c'est intéressé à maintes
reprises de manière occasionnelle à la
question des ovnis contrairement au
discours officiel qui est de dire on a
retiré nos billes la question des ovnis
en 1969 les conclusions étaient publiées
début 1970 puis on avait rien trouvé de
très intéressant en fait on avait trois
grandes conclusions la fin du projet
Bluebook qui s'est pas appelé toujours
Bluebook en 1947 ça s'appelait d'abord
le projet signes c'est devenu ensuite le
projet Bluebook et en 1969 après 22 ans
d'enquête en pleine guerre froide donc
les Américains avaient intérêt à savoir
ce qui volait au-dessus des États-Unis
donc on met fin à ça et pourquoi à 69
mais parce qu'on a 16 d'utiliser les
avions espions on passe au satellite non
ça devient moins intéressant donc on
tire nos baies on dit ben voilà on
s'intéresse plus la question des ovnis
et ce qu'ils disent c'est on n'a jamais
nié contrairement à ce que au discours
des amateurs d'ovnis qui durant le
gouvernement ni l'existence des ovnis
pas du tout en
196569 publication 70 ils disent non non
on a étudié 12618 observations d'OVNI
sur les 12618 et en de 701 pour
lesquelles on a pas trouvé
d'explications donc c'est un aveu noir
sur blanc un phénomène ovni ils disent
de ce nombre de non-identifiés on a rien
vu qui menace de sécurité nationale et
enfin rien dans ces codes de
non-identifiés témoignent d'une
technologie supérieure d'origine
extraterrestre voilà et à partir de si
on envoyait une demande citoyenne au
gouvernement américain au Département de
la Défense sur les ovnis la réponse
était toujours la même on a cessé de
s'intéresser aux ovnis avec la fin du
projet Bluebook
voilà qu'en 2017 le New York Times
publie un article en disant c'est pas
tout à fait vrai le gouvernement
américain site est intéressé de manière
plus ou moins cyclée qu'au phénomène de
OVNI et en particulier entre 2007 fin
2007 début 2008 et 2012 ils avaient un
programme dont l'acronyme voulait dire
programme d'identification avancée des
menaces aérospatiales et le programme
est donc ils ont c'est un projet qui
était quand même modeste on parle ici de
20 millions sur 4 ans et demi à peu près
alors quand on sait c'est ça que le
budget annuel du département de la
défense c'est 700 milliards dans l'année
un projet de 20 millions sur 4 ans c'est
pas grand chose on voit que la loi c'est
de la monnaie du fond d'une poche bon
bref c'est intéressant à ça et en même
temps que l'article est sorti on nous a
présenté trois vidéos qui somme toute on
nous dit que c'est extraordinaire mais
en réalité pour l'oeil de la commode des
mortels on voit rien c'est un image on
noir et blanc puis on voit un point noir
au milieu puis là bon entende le pilote
derrière quelque chose
scientifique cela
c'est beau c'est ça bon donc on voit pas
grand chose l'objet qui est qui envoie à
l'écran c'est une image qui était captée
par le radar on a des données
télémétriques et des données
télémétriques nous disent que c'est un
objet qui se trouve un kilomètre de
distance qui se déplace à la vitesse de
500 km/h à la vitesse finalement d'un
autre avion il y a rien d'extraordinaire
là-dedans on voit pas de technologie
extraterrestre et là donc à partir de là
on a toujours à peu près les 5 6
semaines personnes c'est un espèce de
Momentum ces gens-là sont très bruyants
dans les médias et réussissent à faire
mousser enfin que là ils sont à Joe
Rogen et ailleurs il parle il parle il
parle je pense notamment des gens comme
Jeremy Corbel
Georgina donc ce sont des gens qui sont
populaires on les voit partout et là peu
à peu ça fait monter la sauce c'est
éventuellement des gens pro OVNIs ou des
beaux congrès américains sont déjà assez
curieux nous pilotes voient des trucs et
on veut savoir donc ça fait mousser la
chose mais aujourd'hui on en est rendu
il y a eu l'article la publication des
vidéos le témoignage de pilote qui
raconte des histoires vieilles parfois
de 20 ans parce que les événements ces
fameuses vidéos remontent principalement
un événement qui s'est produit en 2004
sur un navire au large de San Diego qui
était le USS limites mais 2004 là
c'était il y a quand même 18 ans de ça
donc ces gens-là racontent un événement
vieux de 18 ans qui vont à 600 km donc
puis l'objet qui se c'est bon il faut
calculer la vitesse de déplacement de
l'objet mais la propre vitesse de
déplacement de ton avion bon il y a
plusieurs éléments qu'on doit tenir
compte et là ça a moussé des gens
congrès on voulait avoir la réponse à ça
ils ont fait pression le département de
la Défense hors récemment mis en place
deux comités en fait pour enquêter sur
les ovnis un ou au sein du Pentagone un
au sein de la US Navy mais
éventuellement tu dis ouais mon nez 5
ans plus tard là on a toujours rien
c'est 5 ans plus tard on a quoi on a
beaucoup de Monsieur en cravate son uno
racontait plein d'affaires mais elle est
où cette dernière preuve qu'on attend
depuis 80 ans elle est nulle part des
bouts de films qu'on va pas grand chose
des gens qui racontent des histoires
comme si c'était la première fois que
des pilotes racontaient des histoires
d'ovnis on a plein les pages du projet
Bluebook des pilotes civils des pilotes
des pilotes militaires qui ont raconté
avoir vu des trucs bizarres mais la
preuve elle est toujours pas là on a
beau monter au congrès au Pentagone
monter les barricades se mettre des
antennes sur la tête
un moment donné faudra arriver avec une
preuve quelque chose mais on aurait
absolument donc je comprends que moi
pour moi je suis pas très impressionné
ce que je vois là ce serait trop long de
raconter ça mais ce que je vois là ça
c'est déjà passé dans l'histoire
américaine ça s'est passé en fait à la
fin des années 80 début des années 90 il
y a eu un phénomène qu'on a appelé la
peur satanique les gens voyaient le
diable partout ils avaient infiltré
toutes les sphères de l'activité humaine
et au Congrès ils étaient dans les
écoles on le voit un peu aussi avec
canon
méchants satanismes rien de nouveau sous
le soleil à l'époque lorsqu'il y a eu
cette peur cette année ça a été partout
ça a remonté au Congrès le Congrès comme
dans l'histoire des ovnis là le Congrès
dit on veut savoir ce qui se passe que
tu dis sataniste qui mange nos bébés on
se racontait qu'il y avait 50000 bébés
qui étaient assassinés chaque année aux
États-Unis 50 000 bébés ça commence
beaucoup et comme aucun personnellement
et jusqu'à temps que finalement on
voulait avoir des réponses et on a
chargé le FBI donc été sur ces histoires
là et l'enquête a été menée entre 1989
et 1991 et le chef enquêteur Quenette
l'année a déposé son projet en 91 pour
dire que c'est de la foutaise il y a
rien de ce qui existe c'est pas vrai il
y avait des petits groupes cette année
je dois à gauche à droite là qui fait un
short piéton au bal cimetière des bébés
assassinés il y a pas ça il y a pas il y
a pas de l'idée qu'on se fait du
satanisme hollywoodien avec des
ramifications partout des gens des
quatre noix ça existe pas ça c'est un
Hollywood cette réalité-là n'existe pas
donc il y a des gens quelques poignée
d'individus qui ont réussi à l'époque à
faire monter la ferme mousser la faire
jusqu'à ce que ça vaille au Congrès et
que finalement les autorités se
saisissent de l'affaire donna une
impression de sérieux derrière ça et
c'est exactement ce qui se passe c'est
que les ovnis là on a l'impression que
c'est très sérieux là parce que tout le
monde embarque là-dedans mais moi je
serais prêt à mettre des peuvent engager
que dans un an ou deux ans là cette fois
dit là vous retomber
une dernière le monde
dans le cas du monde du Loch Ness ou le
Bigfoot ça c'est des sujets intéressants
où on peut faire de la bonne science on
l'a vu dans le cas du monstre du Loch
Ness c'est à dire qu'on a des
témoignages on les premiers témoignages
remontent à l'Antiquité là à l'Antiquité
ou des je dirais on le premier
témoignage c'est 565 à peu près après
Jésus-Christ donc on a les premiers
témoignages une bête dans le lac mais
principalement pour ce qui nous
intéresse là l'homme moderne les
observations vont se multiplier à partir
de 1933 le long du Loch Ness parce qu'on
a construit une route qui longe Liberge
donc sur plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres les gens ont une vue dégagée
du Loch Ness et là il va y avoir ces
témoignages on voit des créatures on
voit quelque chose d'étrange
et tout ça est une question de foi il y
a plusieurs tentatives scientifiques qui
ont été menées dans les années 60 et 70
qui ont jamais pu déterminer la nature
ou la non nature du monstre du Loch Ness
donc on était dans un aspect folklorique
et un moment donné arrive la science et
la science nous apporter une réponse
définitive donc on est à ce moment-là en
2000 j'espère c'est oui j'espère c'est
oui
on est en 2000 et là il y a un
scientifique de l'université d'Otago en
Nouvelle-Zélande dénommée gamelle Neil
Gamel qui décide de qui est un
spécialiste de l'ADN environnemental or
on le sait tous les animaux contaminent
leur environnement que ce soit par des
excréments des résidus de peau peu
importe et l'ADN environnemental permet
particulièrement dans des milieux aqueux
la rivière etc de déterminer les espèces
qui vivent dans ce milieu-là donc Nil
Gamel se rend au Loch Ness il va prendre
200 échantillons d'eau principalement
dans l'endroit où le monstre apparaît le
plus souvent la baie de requin et il va
analyser va faire un séquençage de ça et
la réponse est définitive il n'y a aucun
animal inconnu dans le Loch Ness à moins
que cet animal là fait jamais pipi caca
dans le lapin mais il y a aucun animal
inconnu dans le Loch Ness par contre les
relevés ADN montrent qu'il y a
énormément d'anglais beaucoup plus
dansés qu'on le croyait les populations
dans gays sont très nombreuses donc
forcément les gens auraient peut-être vu
des engagés ces éléments-là ajoutés au
folklore d'un animal inconnu mais on ne
répond scientifique il n'y a aucun
animal inconnu qui vit dans le Loch Ness
mais des populations d'anguées très
nombreuses merci bonsoir on a fait de la
même chose avec le Bigfoot ça squatch
qui est dessus donc ça donne une idée
inconnue là encore une fois on avait
toute une communauté de gens qui
disaient on a des preuves mais des
scientifiques font la source d'oreille à
nos réclamations on a des excréments on
a des poils on ne si on a ça et puis
éventuellement il y a un scientifique
qui a dit
Brian sax et je suis qui travaille à
l'université de qui était à l'époque à
l'université de de Cambridge en
Angleterre qui dit ben voilà si c'est
vrai que vous avez des échantillons lui
est un spécialiste de l'ADN et c'est moi
je suis intéressé de faire des analyses
de ça déterminer si un hominidé inconnue
alors ce qui va se produire c'est qu'il
va lancer un appel à tous ces gens qui
prétendent d'avoir des échantillons
biologiques de l'animal il va recevoir
une cinquantaine d'échantillons de ces
50 échantillons ils devaient emmener
pendant conserver que 37 les autres
étant ou bien identifiés de prime abord
ou des fibres synthétiques que l'on
disait être des poils d'animaux et il va
analyser ces échantillons certains
proviennent soi-disant du Bigfoot ça se
squash d'autres proviennent du Yéti et
il va faire une analyse de soleil de
tous les analyses qu'il fait et on n'a
aucun qui provient d'un hominidé inconnu
ce sont toujours soit des poils de
chèvre des poils de de yak des poils de
chevaux des excréments de d'autres types
d'animaux mais jamais
donner une idée inconnue ça veut pas
dire que cette animal là le Bigfoot ça
squatte n'existe pas mais s'il existe on
n'a jamais eu entre les mains ou un
laboratoire n'a jamais eu entre les
mains un échantillon biologique d'une de
ses créatures donc pour l'instant le
dossier reste ouvert mais ceux qui
prétendaient détenir de tels
échantillons ben ils ont pas fait la
preuve de leurs affirmations
fascinant merci infiniment ça me fait
plaisir ta connaissance c'est sans
limite c'est incroyable
faudra se faudrait se reparler un
éventuellement pour continuer la
discussion parce que exactement